1, 2, 3, 4.
Wer endlich begriffen hat, dass das Internet aus mehr besteht als nur dem World Wide Web, der kann in den nächsten Gang schalten. Das Netz bietet eine Menge Informationen. Doch wie guckt man an sie ran? Der Internet-Einsteiger hat es schwer, die Datenfluhe zu bändigen. Und hat man einmal eine Information gefunden, wie findet man sie wieder? Wie unterscheidet man richtige Informationen von falschen und wem kann man vertrauen? Chaosradio beleuchtet die Methoden der Internet-Spezialisten. Suchmaschinen, Recherche-Datenbanken und Mailinglisten bieten dem erfahrenen Anwender gute Werkzeuge, um an die Informationen jenseits der Shockwave-Animation und ActiveX-Vergewaltigungen zu kommen.
Herzlich willkommen beim Chaos Radio Computer Blumen, hier im letzten Mittwoch im Monat bei Fritz. Jetzt hätt ich über die Sounds fast vergessen, dass wir ja auch noch reden wollen heute in den nächsten drei Stunden, denn so soll es im Chaos Radio sein. Hier bei Fritz Sending Out Signals sind die DJs heute live an den Decks. Die ganze Zeit also bis 1 Uhr Live-Musik hier von Sending Out Signals. Ansonsten habt ihr gerade gehört in der Einleitung von Tim, dass es heute im Chaos Radio darum gehen wird, wie man das Internet für das benutzt, für was es überall angepriesen wird, nämlich als Informationsbeschaffungsmedium, Instrument. Wie komme ich an die Infos ran, die ich brauche? Und wie finde ich sie wieder, wenn ich sie irgendwann mal gefunden habe? Heute mit neuer Besetzung so ein bisschen. Wer ist denn alles da? Erstmal Mikros checken hier wieder.
Tim ist wieder da.
Tim ist zu leise heute mal.
Alle zu leise.
Frank ist auch da. Frank ist immer schön. Und Wau ist da heute zum ersten Mal.
Du klingst so ein bisschen wie aus der Toilette, Johnny.
Also ich regle noch.
Holla.
Und warum kling ich so komisch?
Das klingt alles wie aus der Toilette, wenn du mich fragst.
Das komische ist immer, dass wenn man vier Mikros auf hat, dann wird's schwierig. Jetzt kling ich ein bisschen besser. Kriegen wir noch hin. Ansonsten mach ich eure Mikros einfach zu.
Ganz einfach.
Was ganz neu ist, im letzten Monat hat sich nach der D2-Aktion noch irgendwas Wichtiges erwähnen sollte?
Na ja, die D2-Aktion hat ganz schön Wellen geschlagen. Da haben wir doch irgendwie eine Wurme mit erzeugt. Ansonsten, meine Premiere ist geknackt. Und so ein Telefonkarten kann man kopieren. All die Dinge, von denen wir dachten, bisher, dass sie nicht so einfach gehen, dass es noch ein bisschen dauert, war geworden.
Was heißt Premiere ist geknackt?
Na, es gibt ein Programm, das kann man sich auf seinen PC laden, eine billige PC-TV-Karte reinstecken, und dann kann man auf seinen PC-Monitor Premiere gucken. Ach, zwar in nicht allzu brillanter Qualität, aber für den Beweis, dass es geht, reicht es.
Um es gleich klarzumachen, das war jetzt nichts, was der Chaos Computer Club ausgehackt hat, sondern es gibt ja auch noch viele andere kreativ tätige Menschen in diesem Land und anderen Ländern vor allem. Allerdings kann man über unsere Website auch an die notwendigen Informationen reinkommen.
Und ich komm jetzt erstmal gleich an die Informationen, wie wir hier einen besseren Sound kriegen. Das ist besser, glaube ich.
Ist schon nicht mehr ganz aus dem Klub.
Ist zwar immer noch ein bisschen kandesetzungsmäßig, aber geht nicht.
Ja, bei vier Mikros in dem kleinen Raum hier ist es schwierig.
Was hat er denn jetzt verändert?
Wir haben jetzt genau ausgepegelt. Ah, sozusagen. Wir sind jetzt knapp unter 0 dB alle und da das Übersprechen der Mikros und so weiter und so fort.
Ah, der digitale Aufbau von Sofa ist im Klub.
So, Bau, über Bau kann man ja einen oder anderen Satz verlieren, oder? Was machst du denn in Berlin eigentlich?
Ach, Nika hat sie ja verschlagen.
Bist du jetzt ständig hier? Man muss dazu sagen, dass du eigentlich CCC Dienstältester, kann man das sagen?
Na ja, auf jeden Fall Ältester, würde ich sagen.
Er ist halt unser Alterspräsident, genau. Genau, 42.
Ich weiß gerade fragen, wie alt muss man sein um Chaos Computer Club?
Echt?
Ich bin der Präsident auch. Vielleicht muss man sein um was zu machen?
Um Dienstältester, ähm ältester Präsident oder was hast du gerade gesagt zu sein?
Ja, du musst genau 42 sein.
Also wenn ich jetzt 43 wäre, dann würde ich VOW ablösen zum Beispiel.
Nee, du wirst nur ältester wenn du 42 bist. Achso, das ist doch die ehemalige Zeitung.
Man muss immer 42 sein.
Ja, mal wieder ein bisschen süßliche Luft geschnuppert in Amsterdam. Und da gab es auch ein bisschen Anlass zu. Da haben die holländischen Hacker irgendwie ihren 5-jährigen Abschied vom Underground gefeiert sozusagen. In Holland ist es ja so, dass die sich da eigentlich relativ schnell auch den professionellen Dingen zugewandt haben. Das heißt, sie sind Internet-Service Provider geworden. Also was heißt jetzt die Hacker? Es gab da halt so eine Gruppe Hektik. Das ist halt so eine Gruppe von Leuten, die unter anderem immer auch dieses Hacker-Festival veranstaltet, die HIP. Und unter anderem daraus hervorgegangen war halt damals eine Mailbox, die hieß Access for All, also XS4ALL. Das ist auch der Server, der dann später diese Radikalgeschichte gesurft hat, wo es hier so viel Aufruhr drum gab. Und die haben jetzt sozusagen ihr fünfjähriges Bestehen gefeiert, mit einer dicken, fetten Party, also sehr angemessen, auch sehr cybermäßig. Es gab dann auf einer kleinen Bühne einen Hack-Me-Contest, da standen also fünf Computer rum. Einer von den jeweiligen Terminals war dann immer per Umschaltbox auf einem großen Display zu sehen. Die haben alle gestartet, auf den Server haben sie eine frische neue Linux-Distribution aufgespielt. Ab dem Moment, wo das Ding installiert war und das erste Mal gebootet war, durften halt alle anderen vier Rechner gleichzeitig versuchen, da einen Kompromiss zu machen, also die System-Security aufzuhacken. Das angenehme war halt, dass das Ganze von einem Systemadministrator noch begleitet wurde, mit dem Mikrofon moderiert wurde. Jetzt hat er noch eine kleine Schwäche aus der Kontaktdatei herausgenommen und hier wird gerade eine neue Sit-Mill-Version gezogen. Das wurde halt immer umgeschaltet, sodass man sehen konnte, was die Angreifer machen, um da reinzukommen und die Verteidiger machten, um sich sozusagen alle Löcher zu stotzen.
Und wie lange hat es gedauert?
Die haben da stundenlang gesessen.
Zwei Mal sind sie, glaube ich, kurz reingekommen. Zwei Einbrüche haben sie geschafft.
Das angenehme war halt, dass es so eingebettet war, weil das ganze Ding war nicht nur so eine Hacker-Geschichte, sondern legte einen DJ dazu auf und der hörte halt so zu, irgendwie versuchte, sich ein bisschen in die Stimmung reinzufühlen, machte halt auch entsprechend die Musik dazu. Wenn es dramatischer wurde, wurde es halt immer ein bisschen dramatischer mit der Musik und so.
Das war auch nur ein Raum, da gab es noch eine große Party-Saal, das war das Paradiesel in Amsterdam, das ist eine große. Jetzt wahrscheinlich auch, naja, viel Tamtam. Und vorher wurde halt auch noch ein bisschen Content gemacht. Da war halt so sozusagen die offizielle Hack-Vertretung aus den USA da. Es gibt ja auch eine mit uns befreundete Organisation, die 2600. Das ist ein Hacker-Club, der in New York ist. Dann gibt es dann insbesondere den prominenten Vertreter Emmanuel Goldstein, der sich sozusagen selbst nach 1984 benannt hat, der auch einer der meist beobachteten Personen in den USA ist, wie man ganz sicher annehmen kann.
Bringt auch dieses Heft raus selber, ne?
Genau, er ist schon so ein echter Public Enemy.
Die haben früher so eine hübsche Serie in diesem Heft, was ja ungefähr wie die Datenschleuder ist für ein Chaos Computer Club, wo wir euch nachher noch mal sagen, wo ihr die bestellen könnt. So ist dieses Fernsehen von 2600. Und die haben so eine Serie gehabt, wo sie öffentliche Telefonzellen dran sind.
Immer hinten drauf, immer vier Telefonzellen. Also falls ihr irgendwie tolle Fotos habt von öffentlichen Telefonzellen, irgendwo auf diesem Planeten, dann schickt sie an 2600. Das ist aber sehr dankbar. Bisher ist der Stoff auch noch nicht ausgegangen.
Also er hat auch schon etliche hundert oder tausend zusammengesagen. Den nächsten wird es ihn wohl auch im Internet als Datenbank geben, wenn man irgendwo hinführt und vorher wissen will, wie die Telefonzellen aussehen.
In Vorbereitung. www.2600.com Und das ist schon mal eine ganz gute Leistung, aber im Wesentlichen geht es nicht so sehr um Telefonzellen bei der 2600, sondern man kann schon klar sagen, dass das sich bei den Hackern in den USA, also in das besondere Umfeld der 2600, wirklich um politische Kämpfe handelt. Es gibt da so ein absolut beherrschendes Thema, was sich kurz mit dem Namen des Betroffenen zusammenfassen lässt. Kevin Mitnick, ein Hacker, der in den USA zu unangenehmen Ruhm gekommen ist.
Der gilt also halt als der Böse. Der hat halt irgendwie ein paar komische Sachen gemacht, ist halt irgendwie weniger ein sehr, sehr guter Hacker als ein extrem guter Social Engineer. Also der kann halt Leute ziemlich gut zu Sachen beschwatzen und so. Und hat irgendwie alle möglichen Sachen gemacht, war irgendwie einmal im Knast und ist danach wieder auf Bewährung rausgekommen. Und hat es dann, glaube ich, über ein Jahr vor dem FBI auf der Flucht gewesen für diverse Geschichten, die man ihm teilweise anhängen wollte, die er möglicherweise auch teilweise begangen hat. In dem Fall sitzt er jetzt seit drei Jahren ohne Prozess im Knast so und die verweigern ihm halt jeglichen Zugang zu irgendwelchen Facilities. Also der kann halt nicht irgendwie die Akten einsehen mit seinen Beschuldigungen. Der kann die Beweise nicht einsehen, weil die Beweise irgendwie 12 Gigabyte sind, die auf irgendeinem Computer liegen und der Richter hat entschieden, weil er halt irgendwie der gefährlichste Hacker der Welt ist. In den Augen des Richters darf er noch nicht mal einen Computer von Weitem sehen. Und sie verweigern ihm gelegentlich den Zugang zum Telefon, weil sie halt der Meinung sind, der könnte halt mit dem Telefon Atomraketen starten oder so. Also die sind da, die drehen da so richtig durch irgendwie. Und der Mitnick war halt nicht so schrecklich beliebt bei den Ami-Hackern, weil er halt auch eine Menge Würbel in der Presse verursacht hat. Aber mittlerweile, dadurch, dass er nur wirklich seit drei Jahren im Knast sitzt und ihm wirklich jegliche Rechte verweigert werden, die er da eigentlich hat, gibt es halt jetzt diese Free-Kevin-Kampagne, die da von den 26er-Nord-Leuten irgendwie massiv mitgetragen wird, um halt irgendwie zu erreichen, dass er halt ordentlich behandelt wird, weil die schon ganz klar sehen, dass Mitnick dann nur als Exempel dienen soll, um halt andere Hacker einzuschüchtern. Also ein klares Beispiel so, ja guckt her, wenn ihr euch daneben nicht nach unseren Regeln spielt, dann können wir euch genauso scheiße behandeln wie die Mitnicks. Und deswegen sind sie halt da doch ziemlich hinterher mit dieser Free Kevin-Kampagne.
Kann man ja vielleicht auch nochmal eine Sendung, vielleicht kann man mal mit 2600 eine Sendung machen über Telefon oder mal gucken.
Das ist ja sehr, sehr vorstellbar.
Ich wüsste auch schon, in welchem Rahmen.
Der Manuel macht auch eine monatliche Radiosendung, ich glaube aber dienstags ist die.
Können wir mal nachgucken, jetzt haben wir ja endlich Internet.
Der hat auch eine eigene Radioshow auf einem Clubradio da. Und bespricht halt auch diese Themengeschichten. Interessanterweise eine ähnlich strukturierte Sendung wie der Blumenboden, mit vielen Hörern und so.
Lass uns noch mal was einfinden. Machen wir was mit denen zusammen und übertragen das vielleicht beides. Wir haben gleich das Fritz Kurz Info. Danach geht es dann los hier mit unserem Thema. Und es wird glaube ich ziemlich intensiv für euch zu Hause auch. Ihr werdet viel anrufen können, Fragen stellen können zum Thema wie finde ich eigentlich die Information, die ich suche im Netz nach einer kleinen Einführung von uns. Abgesehen vom Anrufen etwas später könnt ihr natürlich an dieser Sendung auch teilnehmen, indem ihr euch mit anderen Hörern und Hörerinnen unterhaltet, nämlich entweder bei Fritz als Java-Chat im www. fritz.de. Oder mit einem Telnet-Programm unter www. ccc.de. Das Telnet-Programm wurde mit einem Browser gemerkt. Ich bin ein Browser.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
22.30 Uhr.
Streit. Die Ausländerpolitik der CSU hat am Abend zu einer heftigen Debatte im Bundestag geführt. Die Opposition kritisierte, die jüngsten Beschlüsse der Unionspartei schürten Rassismus. Innenminister Kanter, CDU, verteidigte dagegen die Forderungen nach einem schärferen Ausländerrecht. Abstimmung. Umweltministerin Merkel bleibt im Amt. Die Bündnisgrünen scheiterten im Bundestag mit einem Antrag, in dem die CDU-Politikerin zum Rücktritt aufgefordert wurde. Hintergrund ist die Affäre um die verstrahlten Atommülltransporte. Ziele. Nordrhein-Westfalens neuer Ministerpräsident Wolfgang Clement SPD will versuchen, die Arbeitslosigkeit zu verringern. Außerdem will die rot-grüne Regierung dafür sorgen, dass junge Leute einen Ausbildungsplatz finden. Der Landtag in Düsseldorf hatte den bisherigen Wirtschaftsminister Clement heute zum Nachfolger von Johannes Rau gewählt. Wirkung. In Nordkorea konnte die Hungersnot durch Hilfslieferungen eingedämmt werden. Nach Angaben der Vereinten Nationen ist die Lage aber weiter dramatisch.
Sport.
Fußball in einem BM-Testspiel in Helsinki trennten sich Deutschland und Finnland null zu null.
Wetter.
Abends Schauer oder Gewitter nachts aufgelockert, 12 bis 9 Grad. Morgen freundlich und warm bis 29 Grad. Statt Verkehr Berlin, Charlottenburg. Wegen einer Radsportveranstaltung ist der Kurfürstendamm und die Tauentzienstraße zwischen Joachimsthaler und Nürnberger Straße noch bis 23 Uhr gesperrt und Prenzlauer Berg Richtung Landsberger Allee zwischen Knieprode Straße und Landsberger Allee Sperrung wegen einer Gefahrenstelle.
Falk Zilke mit dem Fritz, kurze Info.
Fritz präsentiert unsere neuen Sprecherpraktikanten.
Fritz präsentiert Nordi Nordborn. Wessi Westborn.
Na, was denn nun?
Ossi Ostborn? Live in Berlin. Montag, 1. Juni in der Arena. Ossi Ostborn.
Und das Ende eines Sprecherpraktikums.
Chaosradio jeden Mittwoch im Monat bei Fritz der Computerblummung sozusagen. Musik kommt von Sending Out Signals live an den Decks und wir erklären jetzt nochmal richtig anständig in Ruhe, worum es heute eigentlich gehen soll.
Ja, die Idee zu dieser Sendung kam uns ja nachdem viele Hörer in den vorigen Sendungen immer wieder gefragt haben, wie geht denn das mit dem Internet, wo findet man denn eigentlich was und wie sind dann die Adressen von den Servern? Wie finde ich denn Informationen und naja, viele Leute wurden von uns ja auch relativ kühl an Suchmaschinen verwiesen, wenn sie halt irgendwas gesucht haben, weil einfach viele Sachen selbstverständlich über Suchmaschinen zu finden sind. Andere Sachen sind halt ein bisschen schwieriger zu finden und da muss man halt schon ein bisschen mehr über das Internet wissen oder auch schon ein bisschen länger dabei sein, um solche Sachen zu finden. Und da dachten wir uns, wir machen mal eine Sendung darüber, wie geht denn das mit dem Internet. Deswegen haben wir die Sendung halt Internet für Fortgeschritt genannt. Also wir wollen halt nicht erklären, was das Internet eigentlich ist oder was ein Browser ist oder was das World Wide Web ist, da gehen wir mal davon aus, dass die meisten Leute es schon wissen, sondern wir wollen uns heute damit beschäftigen, wie man tatsächlich Informationen findet, die nützlich sind, die man gebrauchen kann, die halt im großen, weiten Internet so vorhanden sind.
Eine Suchmaschine hat wahrscheinlich jeder in irgendeiner Form schon mal gesehen. Da gibt es die verschiedensten, ganz ganz viele, die werden wahrscheinlich auch alle fallen, die Namen. Yahoo ist ein Beispiel, www.yahoo.com, da kann man Suchbegriffe eingeben oder unten auch Rubriken suchen. Vielleicht greife ich zu weit nach vorne, wenn ich frage, wie so eine Suchmaschine überhaupt funktioniert. Woher wissen die, wenn ich eine Seite bastel, dass ich über bestimmte Sachen berichte?
Das sollten wir ein kleines bisschen später behandeln. Dazu haben wir noch einen Experten, der eine Suchmaschine betreibt, nachher am Telefon. Wir würden eigentlich erst mal damit anfangen, wie man eigentlich Sachen findet im Internet.
Die einfachste Sache, wenn ich etwas frage, ist, was man überhaupt suchen soll im Internet. Im Internet gibt es alles, das ist sicherlich nicht falsch, aber wahr ist es auch nicht. Tatsächlich ist es so, dass ein großer Teil des Contents nach wie vor aus Computerthemen besteht. Dann kommen jetzt die klassischen Medien, die ihren Content reingeben, sprich alle Zeitungen, der ganze normale Snorkel, den man sowieso schon am Chaos kaufen kann. Der kommt jetzt auch noch mit dazu und macht sich richtig breit. Aber dann gibt es auch noch viele, auch teilweise schon sehr alte Datenbanken. Was wir vielleicht mal vorwegzunehmen als die wichtigste Ressource überhaupt sind, die Quellen sind eigentlich selber da, also die Menschen. Denn man kann ja mit dem Internet nicht nur mit irgendwelchen Web-Servern kommunizieren, sondern das, was eigentlich das Internet hochgebracht hat und was eigentlich der Gedanke dahinter gewesen ist, ist, Leute miteinander zu vernetzen, unabhängig von ihrem Aufenthaltsort. Nicht damals ist das ja im Rahmen wissenschaftlicher Entwicklungen entwickelt worden, das Internet. Und es geht einfach darum, direkt mit den Leuten in Kontakt zu treten. Und das, was man halt normalerweise nicht kann, wenn man sich eine Zeitung kauft, da steht dann halt irgendein Bericht drin über dieses und jenes und so. Und übers Internet ist es in der Regel notwendig, direkt an die Leute heranzukommen, die nun den Grund dafür geliefert haben, dass es diesen Artikel überhaupt gibt.
Das ist ein guter Punkt. Moment hör ich nur einen. Genau, wir wollten gerade mal anfangen damit, wie das eigentlich mit den Suchmaschinen ist. Es gibt ja eigentlich zwei Arten von Suchmaschinen. Einmal die, die eigentlich so große von Menschen geschaffene Datenbanken, von Themen sortierten URLs sind, also sowas wie Yahoo zum Beispiel. Und dann gibt es ja noch so die anderen Suchmaschinen, die eigentlich so den ursprünglichen Typ darstellen, die halt auf der Basis von großen Indizes fungieren und von sogenannten Robotern, die halt das Web abgrasen und halt alle WWW-Seiten, die da so sind, indizieren. Kannst du da vielleicht einfach was Näheres zu den Technologie-Seiten?
Also prinzipiell kann man sagen, Yahoo ist zwar auch eine Suchmaschine, aber sowas wird eigentlich traditionell als Verzeichnis bezeichnet, Verzeichnungsdienst. Die haben später die Technologie dann dazu gekauft oder lizenziert. Das heißt, genau genommen haben die wohl mit AltaVista ein Abkommen gehabt und haben es dann gelingen gekriegt. Das wird jetzt auch interessant, weil Yahoo angekündigt hat, dass sie mit AltaVista nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten wollen, weil die jetzt korrekt mögen. Aber traditionell gibt es mehrere solche Verzeichnisse, in denen man dann auch suchen kann. Der Unterschied ist eben, dass es vorselektiert ist. Traditionell ist es so gewesen, dass vor den Suchmaschinen Verzeichnisse gab, aber im Grunde hat man erst nachdem es die Suchmaschinen gab, entdeckt, dass man eigentlich Verzeichnisse haben möchte, weil das Problem mit Suchmaschinen eben immer ist, dass da wirklich jeder Scheiß drin ist. Also jede private Homepage. Wenn man mal zu einer Suchmaschine geht und nach Under Construction sucht zum Beispiel, dann findet man da Millionen von Hits. Da sieht man eben, das ist nicht sonderlich sinnvoll, aber man findet alles, was Under Construction ist.
Das ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch wahr.
Na ja gut, aber wenn man jetzt ein Bauarbeiter ist oder was weiß ich was sucht, dann hat man halt verloren. Und deswegen ist es schon nicht schlecht, wenn man spezielle Interessen hat, was man da vorselektierte Sachen hat. Und das ist die Idee eigentlich hinter Suchen in Verzeichnissen. Und tatsächlich zeigt sich, dass man für Spezial-Suchgebiete, für spezielle Anforderungen oder eben wenn man ein Profi ist, der keine Zeit hat, irgendwo durchzublättern, also nicht so der Privatanwender, dem es im Grunde egal ist oder der sich dann eben die Suchansprache gut anguckt und ein bisschen Zeit damit verbringt und lernt, wie er die Suchmaschine anständig bedient. So Leute, die professionelle Informationen suchen, die machen das zwar auch, aber zu einem sehr geringen Teil nur und die erwarten eben, dass sie da was angeben und dann kommt eben was. Und das sieht man zum Beispiel ganz gut, wenn man sich mal anguckt, was so auf Suchmaschinen gesucht wird. Abgesehen davon, dass die meisten natürlich nach Text suchen, findet man eben auch so Anfragen, da kann gar nichts rauskommen, wie Microsoft Internet. Also da kann überhaupt nicht klar, was da eigentlich gefragt ist. Und wenn man sowas sieht, dann erwarten die Leute eben, sie geben das ein und viele wollen eigentlich nur mal sehen, so wie viel da eigentlich kommt, um so zu vergleichen, welche Suchmaschine gut ist. Und was auch ganz gern gemacht wird, ist so Ego-Surfing, dass die Leute nach ihrem eigenen Namen suchen und eigentlich ihre Homepage dann sehen wollen und sich wundern, was dann alles passiert. Sowas gibt es eben häufig, aber es zeigt sich eben ganz klar, dass so generelle Suchmaschinen wie Alta Vista erst mal das Problem haben, dass da zu viel Scheiß drin ist. Und zum zweiten, dass das Web einfach sehr viel schneller wächst, als die Platten kaufen können.
Na ja, was heißt zu viel Scheiß? Ich meine, es ist nach wie vor so, dass man mit Alta Vista zum Beispiel relativ zielgerechtet suchen kann. Ich meine, wenn man Microsoft Internet eingibt, gut.
Nein, das ist schon klar, aber es ist halt nicht so, dass man mit Alta Vista auch wirklich alles findet. Also da muss ich sagen, habe ich mich in letzter Zeit doch öfter mal enttäuscht.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass eben die Kraft darin liegt und darum geht es ja hier eigentlich auch, dass man eben diese ganzen Dinge kombiniert und irgendwie die Stärken eines jeden einzelnen Systems herausnimmt. Also man wirklich auf der Suche ist, nach einer bestimmten Information, das ist also angenommen, man möchte jetzt einen... Man sucht einen bestimmten Text, den angeblich eine bestimmte Person in einem bestimmten Institut veröffentlicht hat. So etwas, oder eine Nachrichtenquelle, dann würde ich auch erstmal mit Alta Vista starten und versuchen irgendwie den Namen zu finden. Dann heißt der Typ wahrscheinlich Jeff Miller. So, dann ist natürlich schon mal Essig so mit Jeff Miller.
Da hast du dann natürlich schon viel Info, wenn du weißt, wer den Text geschrieben hat.
Ja, das hört man ja meistens. Es ist neulich ein nettes Gesetz formuliert worden. Da hat jemand gesagt, wenn man mindestens drei völlig unterschiedliche, nicht miteinander zu tunhabenden Sachen sucht, dann kriegt man immer Resumes zurück. Und das kann man mal ganz gut testen, wenn man nach Windows, Unix und irgendwas sucht, was so erstmal von verschiedenenartigen Kundenkreisen benutzt wird. Oder irgendwie einen Buchtitel und dann was, was überhaupt nichts damit zu tun hat, dann findet man sich irgendwelche Resumes und das ist einfach eine Misere. Die ist im Internet, kann man auch nicht verhindern, weil der Computer nicht erkennen kann, wonach man jetzt eigentlich sucht, sondern der kann nur sehen, was man angegeben hat. Und deswegen, es gibt auch kein richtig gutes Verfahren, um, wenn man jetzt 100 Millionen Hits hat, genau die als erste zu listen, die der wahrscheinlich haben will, obwohl es eigentlich alle versuchen. Und es gibt auch Methoden dafür, aber die können natürlich nicht hell sehen. Das ist auch kein echt, kein richtig leichtes Problem.
Weil, dieser so, ja, who ist eigentlich mehr so die chinesische Methode, so man setzt einfach in laufenden Leute hin, die irgendwie durchs Netz klicken und versuchen, irgendwie einigermaßen sinnvolle Sachen zusammen zu finden. Die müssen auch zwangsläufig irgendwie weniger aktuell und weniger vollständig sein, als die initiierenden Suchmaschinen.
Naja, das ist bis zu, also wenn so eine Maschine neu anfängt, dann ja, das hat man so ganz gut gesehen an web.de in Deutschland. Die haben irgendwann angefangen und das konnte man dann ganz gut beobachten, weil sie halt nicht die ersten waren. Und die haben eine Weile lang so Sachen drin gehabt, die halt grad hype waren, aber so Neuigkeiten hat man da nicht gefunden. Und Yahoo! hat halt die kritische Grenze überschritten. Und die müssen im Grunde gar nicht mehr im Netz rumsuchen, weil im Grunde jeder Arsch dahin kommt und erst mal eine Mail schreibt, so könnt ihr nicht meine Homepage aufnehmen. Also die haben keine Leute mehr, die das Netz durchsuchen nach irgendwelchen Neuigkeiten, sondern die haben nur noch Leute, die den E-Mail bergab. Ja, na klar, am Ende ist das gleiche. Aber das ist ganz lustig, wenn man auch nur entfernt wie eine Suchmaschine aussieht, dann kriegt man gleich Tonnen von Mails. Also mir geht das auch so, dass da irgendwelche... Es gibt ja so Dienste, die wir verbinden, sie bei 10 Millionen Suchmaschinen und die schreiben dann wirklich alles, was irgendwie entfernt nach Suchen aussieht, erst mal angeschrieben.
Und das funktioniert auch auf diese Dienste?
Ja, sicher. Die machen dann irgendwie neben 20 Mark und machen dann so eine Art Semispam an Webmaschinen von irgendwelchen Suchmaschinen, die das dann wahrscheinlich wegschmeißen. Aber sicher, es gibt so eine Dienste und es gibt halt auch viele Leute, die das tun und gerne ihre Werbung dann ausziehen möchten.
Wie man sich mit der eigenen Page anständig findbar macht, das werden wir bestimmt auch noch ansprechen.
Ja, genau. Also das ist so ein Wunsch, den viele Leute haben. Aber wenn man sich mal überlegt, welche Konsequenzen das hat, also ich meine, so mal angenommen, alter, wisst ihr, da würde das tun, dass ich da Geld für ausgebe, dass die meine Homepage eben nach vorn und listen. Oder ich finde ein Verfahren, was es mir ermöglicht. Also es gibt so Verfahren, man kann in HTML Stichwörter unterbringen, die nicht zu sehen sind im Browser, aber die von der Suchmaschine mit einbezogen werden. Und das machen vor allem Porno-Types, dass die da eben irgendwelche Sachen einbauen. Und das ist auch schon so gewesen, dass sie zum einen den Namen der Konkurrenz bei eingebaut haben, damit man eben sie findet, wenn jemand nach der Konkurrenz sucht. Und sowas geht natürlich, aber im Grunde ist das dann am Ende nicht so, dass der Kunde dann gewonnen wird, den man so kriegt, dadurch, dass er bei der Suchmaschine eben den Hit findet, sondern der fühlt sich im Gegenteil abgestoßen und sagt, hey, das ist eine scheiß Suchmaschine, die gibt mir völlig Mist zurück. Und geht halt woanders hin. Also das ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert und das ist sicher eine Sache, die so mit am häufigsten gefragt wird. Und das sieht man ja auch, wenn man mal in den Buchladen geht. So der Haufen von Literatur, der verspricht, wie man mit Suchmaschinen nach oben sich raten kann, der ist ein eigenes Regal.
Da fällt mir auch irgendwie was Schönes ein. Also ich hab irgendwann mal nach Scientology Geschichten gesucht bei Alter Vista. Tipp halt erst mal Scientology ein, erst mal gucken, ist schon eine Weile her. War dann sehr überrascht, als dann schon bei meiner nächsten Suchanfrage fette Scientology Werbung ganz oben in den Banner prangte. Also das ist eben auch so, dass in dem Moment, wo man nach einem bestimmten Begriff sucht, der nicht nur im Netz, sondern der sucht auch noch an seiner ganzen lokalen Werbedatenbank und sucht dann gleich das passende raus.
Alter, bist du das da besonders positiv? Neulich suchte ich mal nach eurem Mobile-Phone, Hacking, Reprogramming und noch irgendwie sowas und bekam dann oben gleich irgendwie eine Werbung von Nokia. Wie toll sicher doch ihre Telefone sind, irgendwie eingeblendet. Also die wissen schon, was sie da tun sollen.
Funktioniert auch im Musikbereich, wenn du nach Bands suchst, kriegst du gleich CD Now oben und weiß nicht was alles.
Ja, das ist aber echt super schienabhängig. Also der, der das am aufdringlichsten macht, das Alter Vista.
Ja, zweifelsohne. Also was ich wirklich irgendwie verstörend fand, ist, dass irgendwie zunehmend Pornos sich mit irgendwelchen technischen, also wirklich so abstrustechnischen Begriffen halt irgendwie als Suchkriterien irgendwie reinbauen. Man kriegt irgendwie regelmäßig, selbst wenn man nach irgendwelchen Ship-Layouts sucht, bekommt man irgendwelche Pornos als ersten Hit.
Das ist aber nichts Neues, das haben sie schon in T-Online gemacht, war das ja alles alphabetisch und sie haben sich halt als A-A-1-1-1-1-1 eintragen lassen und waren sozusagen bei allen Listen immer ganz vorne.
Wunderbar, funktioniert.
Aber von Pornos kann man nur lernen, die waren bisher immer ganz ganz ganz vorne und wenn irgendwas die Technologie da vorne bringt, dann ist es das.
Ja, daran erkennt man noch, dass die Technologie Zukunft hat, wenn die Porno-Anbieter sich drauf stürzen.
Video, Recorder, CD-ROM, ich denke auch.
Ich habe vor kurzem eine Sache gemacht, und die haben festgestellt, dass von der Bandbreite in ihrem Netz 80% von dem, was die Leute im Netz machen, eben ein Porno gucken ist. Und dann haben sie versucht, das zu unterbinden, haben da irgendwie so merkwürdige Software gekauft, die so 2-3 Zeit rausgefiltert hat, aber sowas lässt sich natürlich immer umgehen. Und dann haben sie nach einem halben Jahr festgestellt, dass das nicht bringt, und haben es dann auf 60% gesenkt, indem sie da übelste Sachen angedroht haben. Aber so richtig verhindern kann man das nicht. Und letztendlich, ich meine, je mehr Ärger man versucht, den Leuten zu machen, desto eher ist das eine Herausforderung für die Leute, es dann doch irgendwie hinzuziehen. Und letztendlich glaubt man, das kann man nur so mitnehmen, wie man eben auch Werbung und Zeitungen überall und Litfersäulen im Straßenbild mitnimmt.
Also vielleicht sollten wir nochmal so ein bisschen auf den Track kommen, wie man am besten vorgeht, wenn man wirklich etwas finden will. Und ich denke, was relativ wichtig ist, ist zunächst einmal ein Verständnis dafür zu entwickeln, wie eigentlich diese ganzen Suchinformationen, auf denen sich die Suchmaschinen aufbauen, wie die sich eigentlich ergeben. Da ist natürlich zunächst einmal der Inhalt der Webseiten, das heißt diese Suchmaschinen durchsuchen das ganze Internet automatisch nach irgendwelchen URLs, wo wiederum links drin steht, denen sie dann wiederum folgen und sie holen sich den kompletten Textinhalt rein. Werten mittlerweile auch die Bilder aus, also nicht, dass sie sich die Bilder angucken, aber die Größe, die Namen, das wird alles irgendwie mit auch in dem Index abgespeichert. Man kann also, wenn man irgendwie ein besonderes Bild sucht, das mache ich von Zeit zu Zeit mal, wenn ich einfach mal ein Bild brauche zu irgendeinem Thema, was weiß ich, ich brauche einen Pinguin oder ich brauche eine Zahnbürste und will da irgendwas mitmachen, so, dann ist auch da irgendwie die Suchmaschine mein Tool und suche halt irgendwie Toothbrush.gif, so. Und da finde ich dann halt auch einfach sofort was. Oder ich suche halt irgendwie das Toothbrush Museum und auch da kann man also auch schnell irgendwie auf den Trail kommen. Also schon so einfache Sachen.
Also so URL-Raten ist tatsächlich irgendwie ein sehr wirksamster Mittel, um irgendwie Sachen zu finden, so. Also, was weiß ich, wenn man halt Sex sucht, irgendwie ist natürlich der erste Weg irgendwie wie sex.com oder in Deutschland halt wie wie Ficken.de und da findet man natürlich dann auch genau das, was man haben will. Es geht sogar irgendwie, also bei großen Firmen, die halt irgendwie so Brand-Names sind, geht es natürlich noch viel einfacher, aber dann kann man auch ziemlich in die Irre laufen, wenn man zum Beispiel nach der Firma Sharp sucht, eine bekannte Elektronikfirma.
Die haben nicht Geld gewohnt.
Die Scharp-Punkten kommen ein und kommen auf eine Zeit von einer ob's quo in der amerikanischen Krankenversicherung, die halt auch aus irgendeinem Grunde Sharp heißt.
Die schneller waren.
Domain-Namen, Rate-Geschichten, funktionieren halt immer so zu 50%, aber meistens kommt man da irgendwie schneller mit zum Ziel, komplizierte Suchanfragen zu stellen.
www.shell.de und das sucht der kleine Junge Feuerwehrautos.
Felix, haben wir noch Fragen an Felix?
Wir können ihn ja erstmal ranlassen.
Lass ihn nochmal dran. Genau, ein bisschen.
Chaos Radio bei Fritz, Musik kommt von Sending Out Signals, Inhalte kommt von Zeden CC. Chaos Computer Club bei Fritz, jeden letzten Mittwoch am Monat und es geht um Suchmaschinen bzw. darum, wie ich finde hier Information im Internet. Und am Telefon ist immer noch Felix, der begleitet uns ein bisschen. Felix, wir lassen dich einfach so an unserem Gespräch teilhaben.
Ja, genau.
Genau, sitz hier sozusagen.
Also, ich wollte gleich mal anknüpfen an das, wo wir gerade waren. Jetzt ist schon wieder dieser Toiletten-Effekt.
Könntest du das reduzieren?
Also, wir haben sozusagen diese Suchmaschinen. Also, das ist das, was irgendwie auch eine unglaubliche Awareness hat. Also, jeder weiß, da gibt es das Internet und da gibt es diese Suchmaschinen. Ich kann mich noch ganz gut daran erinnern, vor drei Jahren, als das mit dem Internet halb losging, damals, in Anführungsstrichen, kannten wir alle Webseiten. Also, es war einfach ein Tagesereignis, wenn eine neue Website aufmachte und man hatte den ganzen Tag Zeit, die sich anzugucken und am nächsten Tag gab es vielleicht eine neue und wir waren überrascht, dass wir in der Woche, und dann manchmal halt auch schon zwei pro Tag, so dass das auf einmal so explodierte, so ich meine, mit der Geschwindigkeit derzeit, kann man das schon gar nicht mehr vergleichen, so aber das Ganze war echt noch überschaubar, das war nach einem halben Jahr, war dann auch Schluss. Und auf einmal entstand eigentlich erst der Bedarf, nach diesen Suchmaschinen, die vorher eigentlich überhaupt gar kein Mensch bedürzt hat, weil da gab es irgendwie eine Linkpage, da war irgendwie das halbe Internet drauf, oder zumindest das, was relevant war, das kannte man sowieso irgendwie auswendig. Und dann kam halt, ich glaube, der erste, mit einer der ersten Suchmaschinen, korrigiere mich Felix, aber ich glaube, das erste war der World Wide Web Worm. Ja, die stimmen, Web Crawler war auch schon so ein bisschen zu dem Zeitpunkt, da weiß ich auch nicht, wer da ist. Also das waren aber glaube ich so mit die beiden ersten.
Und die fanden es echt cool, dass es sowas gab.
Das war dann überhaupt erstmal eine Entdeckung. Und das war ja dann auch der Beginn einer ganz neuen Zeitrechnung, dass ein Server versuchte, alle anderen Informationen in irgendeiner Form gedrungen, minimiert in sich aufzunehmen und für andere suchbar zu machen. Also diese Indizes zu bilden.
Führt das jetzt zu weit, aber es wurde doch auch vorher versucht, schon Informationen zu bündeln und zu finden.
Also Internet?
Also der größte Schritt war halt, dass ich als kleiner Student dahingehen kann und kann eine Anfrage stellen, die, also wenn ich so zur Bank gegangen bin, so was ja vorher Paradebeispiel war oder zu meinem Broker und gesagt habe, sag mir mal was über Firma so und so, dann habe ich da halt richtig Kohle für abgedrückt und deswegen haben das die wenigsten Hobbyisten überhaupt probieren können. Und also ich weiß noch, das war richtig Goldrausstimmung, als dann die Suchmaschinen da waren und man dahingehen konnte und man konnte so sich selbst suchen und dann voll Freude feststellen, dass er genau eine Seite gefunden hat, nämlich die eigene Homepage. Und ich meine, das Schöne war ja damals war das Internet noch richtig langsam, das heißt, ich war aber in Amerika, da hat man noch irgendwie mal eine Minute gewartet, bis da die Antworten kamen und dann kamen.
Und man fand es toll.
Genau, das fand ich toll, weil man das Gefühl hatte, da tut sich was, da wird noch gearbeitet, ist heute bei Alta Vista immerhin, stellt eine Morzansfrage, wartet 0, 3 Sekunden, das ist ja nicht mehr befriedigend. Also, da arbeitet jemand für fünf Jahre. Also, die ersten waren ja auch noch ziemlich langtäumlich, das war nicht unbedingt das Internet im Schuld war, aber die ersten waren dann schon irgendwelche kleinen Unis gehostet, Studentenprojekte. Übrigens gibt es jetzt wieder einen interessanten Ansatz, der von Studenten gemacht wird. Stanford macht da einen Teil, das sich Google nennt.
G-U-G-L? G-O-O-G-L-E.
Und das Teil, also so heißt der Quorler zumindest, ich weiß nicht mehr, ob die so mal stehen, ich habe auch so einen komischen Namen gehabt. Und das Teil benutzt als Maß für die Güter einer Webseite, wie oft darauf gelingt wird. Das heißt, wenn ich nach, keine Ahnung, suche, irgendwie Siemens, dann finde ich wahrscheinlich die Homepage, weil alle Leute wahrscheinlich auf die Homepage und nicht auf irgendeine kleine Dienstpage irgendwo am Ende der Welt liegen. Und das ist natürlich so für Anfänger eben optimal, weil die ihre Anfragen nicht anständig gestalten müssen, sondern als erstes werden die gelistet, auf die viele zeigen. Das ist eine Sache, das ist eigentlich ein uralter Hut, aber das machen Mathematiker schon seit Ewigkeiten, wenn es darum geht, ihre Papers zu indizieren. Aber im Internet ist das eine ganz neue Idee und ich denke mal, das werden die anderen Suchmaschinen auch bald machen. Also Mathematiker versuchen schon seit längeren Zeiten, ihre Papers gesamt irgendwo abzulegen und super zu haben. Und deswegen hat man sich da überlegt, wie man nun die Güte eines Papers erfinden soll, herausfinden soll bei einer Anfrage. Und da gibt es dann halt ein paar Modelle. Und eins der Modelle ist eben, dass man sagt, wenn es oft referenziert wird, also wenn viele Leute das hinten in ihrer Bibliografie zitieren, dann muss das ein gutes Paper sein. Und genau, das lässt sich ja eigentlich direkt auch selbst übertragen. Wenn Leute darauf linken, ist halt wichtig. Und die Idee ist eigentlich, also mindestens sechs Jahre alt und ich glaube noch deutlich älter. Aber das ist das erste Paper, was ich gesehen habe, was das macht.
Ich habe gerade mal parallel versucht, diese Search Engine Google zu finden. Und wir haben hier so eine Liste, wie finde ich was im Internet. Eins ist URL-Raten. google.com ging schon mal irgendwie in die Hose. Und Punkt 2 ist die Suchmaschine benutzen. Alter, bist du da hochgefeuert? Plus Google, Search Engine war gleich der erste Hit und die URL war google.stanford.edu oder backup.stanford.edu. Und hurra, ich bin sogar irgendwie auf der Seite. Vor allem bin ich das erste Mal auch irgendwie über meinen eigenen Namen auf der Seite, wo mein eigener Name am meisten drin steht. Alter, bist du da immer noch nicht der Feind.
Das ist übrigens echt ernüchternd. Das würde ich allen Leuten mal empfehlen, sich die Suchmaschine in Ruhe im Vergleich anzusehen. Also ein Kriterium, was ich zum Beispiel sehr wichtig finde, ist, dass das Ranking funktioniert. Also unter Ranking versteht man, dass wenn ich eine Anfrage stelle, die 100.000 Hits bringt, dass die ersten, die er mir zeigt, halt die wichtigsten sind. Und das Problem ist zwar nicht hundertprozentig gelöst, aber es gibt ganz gute Heuristiken, die eigentlich so Ergebnisse liefern, die eigentlich schon ganz annehmbar sind. Aber was ich also erwarten würde, ist, wenn ich nach einer Anfrage mache A und B und C, und das sind alles häufige Wörter, und ich mache die gleiche Anfrage nochmal, aber ohne uns, sondern mit oder, dass die ersten 10 Hits in beiden Fällen die gleichen sind, weil die Teilmenge groß genug ist, aber das ist zum Beispiel bei Info-Sieg nicht so. Und da kann man schon mal sagen, das Schwenking-Verfahren von denen ist scheiße. Oder beziehungsweise man kann sagen, die bescheißen, wenn man eben nicht explizit unten hinten haben, die haben einen Shortcut eingebaut, der eben nicht leichter berechnen lässt. Aber sowas sind zum Beispiel Sachen, die ich echt allen empfehlen würde, das mal zu machen mit der Lieblings-Search-Engine. Und sehen, ob das Schwenking-Verfahren halt schon mal funktioniert. Und wenn nicht, dann kann man schon mal irgendwie sagen, dass die Suchmaschine sollte man nur benutzen, wenn die Eingabemenge, die Endmenge klein ist.
Von Suchmaschinen?
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, ich benutze eigentlich ganz gern Hotboard. Der ist leider ziemlich langsam geworden in letzter Zeit, von da, wo ich normalerweise jetzt surfe. Ansonsten, alter, wisst ihr immer noch, also ich weiß nicht, normalerweise frage ich mehrere Suchmaschinen und gucke dann halt.
Meta-Quala?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich hab irgendwie da steht, ich weiß auch nicht warum. Also ist wahrscheinlich eine gute Idee, aber irgendwie geht über direkt hin.
Sind wir aber auch schon mittendrin, jetzt sind schon irgendwie unheimlich viele Stichpunkte gefallen, Stichwörter gefallen, die den meisten Leuten wahrscheinlich nicht viel sagen. Wir können mal, also sowas wie die Verkettungen von Wörtern zum Beispiel und so, also das muss man einfach wissen. Das wird zwar immer erklärt auf den Suchmaschinen auch, da steht dann irgendwie hier für Tipps und so, aber das macht ja keiner, genauso wenig wie man Bedienungsanleitungen liest.
Da kann ich übrigens eine kleine Statistik zubringen. Also auf der Search Engine, die ich da mal gemacht hab, kann ich vielleicht auch noch einmal erzählen, ich hab in Deutschland einen kleinen Search Engine gemacht, da haben wir wirklich wunderbare Log5 und da kann ich sehen, dass 0, 01% der Leute sich das Manual, hier drin steht, wo man sucht, aber ich kriege trotzdem pro Monat ungefähr 80 Mails von Leuten, die sagen, da kommt aber nur Scheiß, wenn ich da was eingebe.
Da geht dann die höchste aller Regeln, RTFM.
Genau, das ist immer so, das kann ich dafür die Leute dann nicht schreiben.
Johnny, was heißt RTFM?
Read the fucking manual.
The fine manual.
Ich meinte vorhin übrigens, mit dem Versuch nachzufinden...
Außerdem ist das die offizielle Erklärung von RTFM, read the manual first.
Ich meinte vorhin mit so Geschichten wie Archie und Gopher, was ist ein dreier Unterschied gewesen, wenn man versucht hat, Sachen zu finden?
Ja, das ist eine interessante Geschichte. Das waren so die ersten Versuche. Früher lagen ja auch viele Informationen nicht im Web, weil das Web war vor vier Jahren eigentlich noch brandneu, sondern da lagen eigentlich die allermeisten Informationen auf FTP-Servern. Und viele Leute hatten halt das Bedürfnis, bestimmte Dateien, bestimmte Namen in diesem FTP-Web, nenne ich das jetzt mal, zu finden. Einer der ersten Ansätze dafür war Anarchi. Das Anarchi-Protokoll, also ein Client, der eigentlich nichts anderes machte, als einen Archi-Server nach dieser Datei zu fragen. Und dieser Archi-Server wiederum tat nichts anderes, als die ganze Zeit FTP-Sites zu durchsuchen, irgendwie LS zu machen, auf denen sich die ganzen Dateien zu merken. Sodass man mit seinem Archi-Client fragte, wo ist Datei sowieso? Der fragte den Archi-Server, der guckte in seinen Index und sagte, da und da und da und da und da liegt die Datei und dann kann man da eben sich das per FTP holen.
Hatte den riesen Nachteil, dass man halbwegs den Dateinamen wissen musste? Ich kann mich daran erinnern, dass wenn man da Sachen gesucht hat und die Dateinamenlänge auch beschränkt ist und so, wenn man nicht wirklich wusste, wie das Ding heißt, dann hatte man Pech.
Das Problem ist heutzutage natürlich noch schlimmer als früher, weil Leute Platten so billig sind. Aber Archie ist übrigens entwickelt worden von ein paar Studenten und das hat dann derartig eingeschlagen, die sich versucht haben, damit selbstständig zu machen. Die haben eine Firma namens Banjib Information Systems gegründet, aber die macht irgendwie nicht viel Kohle. Das ist überhaupt so ein Thema, das sich durchzieht durch das Internet. Das realisieren die wenigsten. Also richtig Geld macht eigentlich niemand. Im Grunde die Einzige, die gerade verdient sind, ist ein Telekom und zwar ein Spawno-Anbieter. Das ist momentan einfach so. Und Archie ist so eine Sache, das haben halt ein paar Studenten gemacht und das hat sich eigentlich als funktionierend herausgesetzt, aber war immer ziemlich langsam.
Aber mittlerweile, muss ich sagen, gerade wo das Web jetzt so irgendwie verstopft, also vom Suchen her verstopft, habe ich manchmal mit Archie super schnelle Ergebnisse. Weil manchmal gibt es einfach den Fall, du suchst, ich meine gerade Windows-Benutzer kennen das ja, da poppt ja irgendwie ein Netscape am laufenden Meter mit, irgendwie diese Datei fehlt mir. So, ja, und gut, die Datei findet man vielleicht nicht, aber manchmal weiß man einfach, was man sucht. Und wenn es eben so ist, dann ist Archie vielleicht 1000 Mal schneller. Aber das ist irgendwie schon eine Liste von 100 FTP-Server, wo die Datei in der aktuellen Version rumliegt, bevor ich irgendwie die Seite von Alta Vista auch nur auf meinem Bildschirm habe.
Ja, das liegt aber daran, dass du nicht Archie benutzt, sondern FTP Search in Norwegen.
Nee, ich benutze Archie in dem Moment.
Ja, Archie ist, das ist Archie-kompatibel, das Teil. Benutzt wahrscheinlich einen Archie-Klein, muss mal gucken, welchen Server er befragt.
Ich kann das einstellen, also ich nehme in der Regel Switch.
Switch in Schweizer. Ja, na gut, also gut, das kann sein, dass es geändert hat. Also vor zwei Jahren war es noch so, dass Archie griechisch langsam war.
Die deutschen Archie-Server sind griechisch langweilig.
Ja, nicht nur die Deutschen, es gab einen richtig großen in Finnland und in England gibt es auch einen richtig großen, bei SunSight ist so eine 12 Prozessor Spark, die hat also genügend Rechenleistung. Und trotzdem war die langsam.
Ich glaube, die laufen auch alle nicht mehr so richtig, die betreiben die nicht mehr wirklich ernsthaft.
Das Problem ist halt Archie-Server-Software kostet eben Geld und deswegen haben das so zwar der Uni sich geleistet, aber das war's dann im Grunde auch. Und heute ist Archie wahrscheinlich wieder schneller geworden, weil es keine Menschen mehr benutzt. Die Leute gehen alles raus.
Genau, genau das ist nämlich der Effekt so. Weil es halt einfach nicht mehr so populär ist, wird es auf einmal wieder wertvoll.
Ja, naja, aber Archie ist auch, also Archie ist eigentlich, FDP überhaupt ist wichtig, wertvoller als Web in meinen Augen, weil sich da viel mehr durchgesetzt hat, dass man in Sachen mirrort. Und zwar kommt es noch daher, dass das Netz sehr langsam war und dass die Leute dann eben automatisiert nach die Sachen kopiert haben auf dem Server in Deutschland. Und das machen vor allem Unis. Das ist auch eine Sache, die mich ein bisschen stört, dass es zwar viele kommerzielle Leute gibt, aber so Provider, die dann auch alle möglichen Sachen ihren Kunden anbieten. Aber FDP machen die Leute immer noch aus Amerika und das blockiert natürlich die Leitung ohne Ende. Und für Web hat man jetzt so eine Art Tollerlösung gemacht, diese Cash-Proxys, aber so ein Netzwerk von sich gegenseitig spiegelnden Server gibt es bei FDP seit 15 Jahren. Und gerade Deutschland, die Unis sind eigentlich überhaupt nicht schlecht, wenn es darum geht, riesige FDP-Mirror zu haben. Und wenn man also irgendwas haben will, dann gibt es eine gute Chance, dass es direkt neben einem auf dem Server schon gespiegelt liegt. Und deswegen ist Archie so wertvoll. Weil selbst wenn jetzt das Netz wieder verstopft, dann kommt am Ende raus, dass man mit Archie eben direkt in der Nachbarschaft einfindet und dass man eben nicht nach Amerika gehen muss.
Man kann vielleicht kurz mal dazu sagen, weil es hier gerade auch im Chat leichte Verwirrung gibt. Archie ist kein Dienst, den man mit einem Webbrowser benutzt, sondern es ist ein extra Client-Programm.
Ein eigenes Protokoll, ja. Es gibt auch einen Webzugang dazu.
Auf dem Mac heißt es Anarchie zum Beispiel. Es ist einfach ein einzelnes Programm, wo auch verschiedene Server, die man befragen kann, fertig eingegeben sind und die kann man erweitern. Dann sucht man da. Aber das führt jetzt vielleicht alles viel zu weit. Ich glaube, wir bleiben einfach im WWW. Wir bleiben im Browser. Wir nehmen einfach mal ein paar praktische Beispiele. Wir können auch mal die Telefonleitung aufmachen und ein bisschen diskutieren.
Ja, die Telefonleitung können wir ruhig aufmachen.
0331 für Potsdam. Ach, was sag ich überhaupt? Wir haben ja hier diese super Jingle.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam 709711 9711.
So, ich glaube wir stellen, wir haben gerade schon ein Gespräch geführt, allerdings nicht on air, da wurde Indexbildung kam als Stichwort, gehen wir gleich mal drauf ein. Ruft uns an, wenn ihr ganz konkrete Fragen zu Suchmaschinen habt oder zum Thema, wie finde ich bestimmte Informationen. Also wenn ihr zum Beispiel schon mal irgendwas gesucht habt und warum findet ihr es nicht genau, wenn ihr schon zum Beispiel irgendwas gesucht habt und frustriert wart, weil ihr nicht das gefunden habt, was ihr eigentlich wolltet, dann ruft ihr an unter 0331 70 97 110 und wir versuchen, das rauszufinden, wie man das besser machen kann. Die Indexbildung, wer zählt da was zu?
Die Frage war, wie machen die denn das eigentlich? Die müssten ja eigentlich eine komplette Kopie von den Seiten irgendwie vorrätig halten. Das ist natürlich vollkommen klar, dass das nicht geht. Alter Vista kann nicht das komplette Internet auf seine Festplatte kopieren. Tatsächlich machen sie halt einen intelligenten... Exzerpt.
Vielleicht erklärst du das einfach, ich bin gerade etwas sprachlos.
Ja, also leider so ist das nicht. Also es gibt eine Suchmaschine, die nur einen Ausschnitt speichert. Zeit gehört dazu und deswegen können die auch nur in ihrem Auszug dann Sachen finden. Also prinzipiell ist es so, eine Suchmaschine muss schon alles, worin sie suchen kann, lokal vorrätig haben. Aber da kann man natürlich komprimieren. Leider ist es ein echt untriviales Problem, Sachen komprimiert zu haben im Index, sodass die weniger Platz auf der Platte kriegen, als sie eigentlich groß sind und dann darin auch noch schnell suchen können. Und deswegen machen das nicht so viele. Und wenn man zu Alta Vista geht, dann stellt man fest, die haben, ich weiß nicht wie viel das war, es waren glaube ich irgendwie 6 Terabyte oder so Plattenplatz, haben die da einfach als Rate Array rumstehen. Und die haben einfach wirklich so viel Platten gekauft. Aber das reicht immer noch nicht, um das ganze Internet zu haben. Und das ist genau das Problem mit den Suchmaschinen, dass die einfach nicht so schnell nachkaufen können, wie sich da was tut. Entweder man entwickelt halt ein neues Verfahren, wie man die Daten besser komprimieren kann. Das ist leider nicht sonderlich erfolgreich. Also es kann natürlich sein, dass zwei Suchmaschinen da was geschafft haben und es nicht publizieren. Aber so bei den Papers, die es so gibt zu dem Thema, sieht es nicht so aus, als wenn da große Durchbrüche gekommen sind seit ungefähr 3 Jahren. Da ist ein Netflix-Paper politisch worden.
Hat das dann wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum du so alter bist und nur 30 Seiten tief indiziert hast?
Genau, und was die Leute halt machen, das Problem haben alle Suchmaschinen. Und da geht man halt unterschiedlich ran. Also wie gesagt, X-Sides, was die machen, ist, dass sie einfach nur irgendeinen Algorithmus auf ihre Seiten loslassen. Und der sucht dann Teilen raus, in denen Sorte vorkommen, die eben ansonsten selten sind in ihrem Wörterbuch und sagen, das ist eine wichtige Zeile und überlebt dann.
Das ist dann sozusagen eine Frequenzanalyse auf den Text oder wie?
Ja genau, und dann haben sie dann intelligente Exzertbildungen und der Rest wird eben rausgeschmissen. Weil sie sagen, es interessiert eh keinen. Und so können natürlich wichtige Sachen verloren gehen. Deswegen ist X-Ride auch nicht sonderlich erfolgreich, wenn es darum geht, so das obskure Dokument zu finden. Andere Leute machen das anders. Infoseek zum Beispiel schmeißt einfach, hat generell den Index die Größe limitiert. Und die haben insgesamt, ich weiß nicht, einen Bruchteil der Dokumente von anderen Leuten. Das ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht, wenn man einen Algorithmus gefunden hat, der zu einer Seite sagen kann, ob es sich lohnt, die zu indizieren oder nicht. Aber so richtig toll ist das natürlich nicht. Aber letztendlich muss ich als User prinzipiell von dem Gedanken schon mal verabschieden, dass wir eine Suchmaschine haben können, die das gesamte Internet indiziert. Also das kann man schon mit einem Rechenbeispiel ad absurdum führen. Ich kann eine Webseite bauen, die beliebig per irgendwelchen CGI-Bins oder sonst was generierten Seiten, ohne das einer Suchmaschine zu sagen, dass die Seite jetzt generiert ist. Einfach beliebig, wie viele Seiten generiert. Also es kann nie eine Suchmaschine geben, die alles identifiziert. Und dementsprechend, also es gibt halt verschiedene Ansätze. Alta Vista versucht, die Seiten rauszufinden, die wichtig sind, und macht es so, dass sie einfach links folgen und dann eine gewisse Tiefe tief gehen. Und wenn eine Seite also ob-skur gelingt, ist dann viel halt nicht wichtig, sagt Alta Vista. Und das ist natürlich auch traurig, weil man eben so die Homepage und die erreichen sie uns-Page findet, aber eben nicht den interessanten Artikel. Aber es gibt halt das Problem von allen Suchmaschinen. Und die einzige Möglichkeit, die es da wirklich gibt, ist die Suchmaschine zu beschränken auf einen überschaubaren Teil vom Internet, sodass dann eben doch noch eine komplette Suche möglich ist. Und eine Möglichkeit zu sowas wäre zum Beispiel, dass man eine Suchmaschine macht, die nur deutschsprachige Dokumente indiziert. Und das ist auch dann das, was noch relativ erfolgreich ist in Deutschland. Fireball, die haben sich beschränkt auf deutsche Seiten und haben dafür einen relativ kompletten Index.
Das heißt also, dass man sich schon mal von den Gedanken verabschieden kann, dass man mit einer Suchmaschine alle Suchanfragen abschlagen kann?
Ja, genau. Es wird immer beschränkt für einen Teilbereich, wo es eine Spezial-Suchmaschine gibt. Deswegen kann ich auch allen Leuten nur wärmstens empfehlen, auch wenn man Alta Vista als Lieblings-Suchmaschine hat, dann doch auch mal andere zu benutzen, besonders wenn man eben nicht findet, was man sucht.
Lass uns mal ein bisschen nach Hörerfragen hören, gucken.
Kurzer Hinweis dazu, Metacrawler ist natürlich da ein ganz guter Ansatz. Das ist halt eine Suchmaschine, die mehrere andere Suchmaschinen gleichzeitig befragt und alle Ergebnisse zusammenfasst. Da kann man eben sehr schön sehen, auf welche Begriffe welche Suchmaschine wie reagiert. Dann kann man sich seine Lieblings-Suchmaschine prima heraus suchen. Machen wir den jetzt einen Anrufer an, Johnny? Du bist jetzt gerade angetippt.
Hi, wer ist denn da?
Hallo, hier ist Thorsten aus Pankow.
Hallo Thorsten.
Ich habe eigentlich mal nur eine Frage. Ihr habt vorhin so ein Liti-Spiel, Sending Out Signals.
Können die mir da bitte nochmal sagen, von wem das ist?
Nee, Sending Out Signals sind die beiden DJs, die hier im Studio stehen.
Können die mir vielleicht nochmal sagen, wie das Liti ist, was die hier spielt haben?
Na ja, da die jetzt seit anderthalb Stunden auflegen, wird es wahrscheinlich ziemlich schwierig. Das vorletzte Stück? Hast du eine Ahnung, was das vorletzte Stück war?
Klingt ein bisschen wie Kraftwerk.
Klingt ein bisschen wie Kraftwerk, meint er. Die Platte heißt F***ing Consumer? Und die Band, oder wer auch immer, heißt IF, also EF? Ah ja, und ist auf Disco B erschienen, das ist das Label. Siehste, so findet man auch Informationen, anrufende Fragen geht meistens ziemlich schnell. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ich suche schon seit längerem im Netz nach einer Seite, wo ich den Wechselkurs Rubel D-Mark finde.
Ah, da gibt es eine sehr geile Zeit.
Aber schönes Thema zum Beispiel, ich suche den Wechselkurs Rubel zu D-Mark. Wie gehe ich denn da vor, wie suche ich denn sowas?
Es gibt eine dedizierte Suchmaschine. Die suche ich dir mal kurz raus.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich den bei Bookmarks habe.
Bookmarks sind nämlich auch noch so ein wichtiges Thema.
Das ist eine Company, die hat so einen irgendwie, ich übersetze alles nach alles.
Da habe ich übrigens auch schon öfter gesucht. Nicht unbedingt Rubel, aber so metrische Umrechnungen.
Bei meiner Ex-Zivilstelle, die deutsch-russischer Austausch hieß, da war sowas aktuell.
Ja, aber sowas braucht man ja öfter mal. Entweder Währungsumrechnungen oder metrische Umrechnungen oder Gewichte, keine Ahnung.
Solche Schrankzahlen, dass es mittlerweile so richtig verdammt nützlich geworden ist. Wenn man es weiß, ja. Neulich festgestellt, dass ich in einer Viertelstunde einen kompletten Trip Amsterdam, London und zurück planen konnte. Mit allen Features, wo sitze ich im Flugzeug, wann geht mein Flugzeug, wo muss ich langgehen, in welchem Terminal komme ich an, welcher Bus bringt mich da raus.
Brauchst du eine Webseite, die genug Geld generiert, damit du es dir auch leisten kannst?
Ich fand es wirklich schon beeindruckend, dass man mittlerweile alles, was mit Traveling zu tun hat, kann man mittlerweile im Internet komplett nachvollziehen, dass man dann mal fliegt mit Eeroflot.
Was übrigens die Reisebüros gar nicht so toll finden.
Ja, Herrgott, das ist einer der Effekte vom Internet, dass diese ganzen Intermediates, diese ganzen Zwischenleute, die werden halt plattgemacht davon. Also alle Leute, die davon leben, dass sie Informationen nur weiterleiten, die werden verabschiedet.
Dafür entstehen neue, ne?
Naja, natürlich.
Infobroking.
Suchmaschinen zum Beispiel.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Also jeder, der einen Reisendrohr hat, weiß nicht, was läuft.
Lass uns das fangermaßen machen. Tim, pack dir die URL mit der Suchmaschine einfach auf die Chaosradio-Feedback-Seite.
Scheiße, CNN hat irgendwie seine blöden Pages komplett reorganisiert. Also es gibt da eine Company, die das macht im Web und die macht das sozusagen auch für andere Websites, wie unter auf CNN Travel, also www.cnn.com/großtravelund da gibt es auch einen Currency-Umwandler, den ich allerdings jetzt gerade nicht aus dem Stand...
Hier gibt es im Chat noch hier Lemp, im Chat schreibt gerade was für Wechselkurse.
www.oanda.com Ja genau, die sind da, oanda.com, genau. Und da kannst du alles nach allem. Und vor allem das Coole daran ist, du kannst auch noch bis zum Jahr glaube ich 1970 zurückgehen und dir auch die Wechselkurse aus den letzten 20 Jahren generieren lassen. Oder ich glaube 90, finde ich.
Machen die zufällig auch EQ-Kurse?
Na dennicht. Ich meine, EQ kannst du ja notfalls selber zusammenrechnen, bis er nur so eine Prozentangelegenheit hat.
Achso, ja über die EU Seiten dann.
Richtig, genau. Musst du halt nur gucken, wie gerade der Anteil im Währungskorb ist, aber das hat ja nicht so viel Spaß.
Na ansonsten, für kleinere Sachen könnt ihr mal zu der UDE gehen, die sind für Finanzlager eigentlich ziemlich prima und da kann man auch ein EQ umrechnen lassen.
Bookmarks sind nämlich so ein Problem eigentlich, weil finden im Internet ist ja so eine Sache, aber viel schwieriger ist eigentlich das Wiederfinden.
Vor allem, wenn man zu faul ist, eine Bookmarks in Ordner zu packen und man dann so eine Riesenliste hat, wie bei mir, wo man auch nicht schnallt, welche eigentlich veraltet und doppelt sind. Hallo, da hat schon jemand aufgelegt. Hallo, wer ist da? Hier ist Chaosradio. Frankie, hallo.
Ich wollte so ein paar Sachen erzählen. Und zwar einmal, meine Lieblings-Suchmaschine ist in der Tat der Metacrawler, weil da gibt es so eine wunderbare, anklickbare Möglichkeit, nach Phrasen zu suchen. Und wenn man da zum Beispiel einen Namen eingibt oder so, vor Nachname, dann klappt das eigentlich ganz gut, nach meiner Erfahrung, in den letzten vier Jahren.
Phrasensuchen ist auch eine, der ist sozusagen die Cure bei Suchmaschinen, weil es können nicht besonders viele richtig gut, weil es natürlich die Index immer weiter aufbläht, wenn man nach Phrasen sucht.
Ja, was beim Meta, dadurch, dass er das über alles streut, kommt da eigentlich ganz gut was raus, muss ich sagen. Ansonsten zu Homepages, zum Beispiel, wollte ich noch ganz kurz bemerken, am besten macht sich das eigentlich, wenn man die einzelnen Suchmaschinen besucht und unter ADDURL denn seine Homepage hat einfach einen Trick, genau.
Da gibt es auch so einen Service, der auch völlig kostenlos ist, der das dann automatisch bei den ganzen Großen macht.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, automatisch wurde schon erwähnt, dass das, naja, also das ist eine gute Methode, das wolltest du jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade erzählen.
Ja, Sachen bei Suchmaschinen-Submitten kann man auch machen, wenn man zum Beispiel das Problem hat, dass man genau weiß, dass zum Beispiel Informationen über diesen und jeden seltenen Chip auf jeden Fall auf der, weiß ich nicht, zum Beispiel Chips-Page von Mitsubishi ist, der aber irgendwie nicht zu finden ist, weil die Suchmaschine auf diesem Server einfach zu dumm ist und irgendwie ordentlich zu indizieren, was man halt tut ist. Man vermittelt halt einfach die Pages und die Subpages, die man da haben will, bei zum Beispiel bei Alta Vista und kommt einen Tag später oder zwei nochmal hin, wenn die dann indiziert worden sind, findet man dann die Sachen prima über Alta Vista. Also kann man halt die Sachen tatsächlich...
Also das sind die extern gelagerten Bookmarks.
Also das ist jedenfalls so, dass wenn ihr das url addet, dann schicken die Jungs, die Roboter haben, dann in ungefähr in einer Woche, später so zeitraummäßig, dann auch ihrem Roboter vorbei und indizieren deine ganzen Seiten und so.
Das kommt auf alle wege.
Also nicht alle, sondern nur die, die Roboter haben. Und dann gibt es noch diese wunderbaren Metatags, die glaube ich vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt wurden. Da gibt es für moderne Suchmaschinen auch eine Möglichkeit, dem Roboter zu sagen, dass er Follow-Index machen soll. Und dann sucht er ab deiner Seite nämlich auch die ganzen Unterseiten ab. Auch die, wo deine eventuellen Dokumente nämlich drin stehen. Dann wollte ich noch ganz kurz sagen zu Homepages. Deine eigene Homepage vielleicht indizieren oder so. Ist ganz nett bei www.homepages.de zum Beispiel. Dann ist man nicht so unter dem Fernern liefen, sondern ist dann ein bisschen zentraler Ansprechteil.
Es gibt übrigens, hier kam gerade noch mal von Lammkamm Netzhip, dass man, wenn man im Netz ein bisschen was lesen will zum Thema Suchen, auf Deutsch auch, gibt es www.suchfibel.de Das habe ich noch nicht gehört.
Wenn wir dabei sind, es gibt auch eine Search-Site, die hunderte von Search-Engines-Listen alles, was er gefunden hat, heißt www.klug-suchen.de www.klug-suchen.de Klug ist aber ein schlechter Name. Da kann man auch ein Stichwort angeben, für welche Suchmaschine man sucht, das finde ich schon lustig.
Ansonsten, um auch ganz kurz den allerletzten Satz zu sagen, zur Nützlichkeit des Internets, ich persönlich finde am allernützlichsten das deutsch-englische Wörterbuch bei Leo Org. Muss ich euch sagen, weil...
Da gibt es eins.
Richtig gut, eigentlich.
Jedenfalls nützlicher als der Babel-Fischball-Alter, der im wirklichen Fall als Humorgenerator funktioniert.
Aber dafür ist er großartig.
Also wirklich, das Ding ist wirklich zum Tod lang.
Kann man gleich auch noch mal ein paar Sätze zu verlieren.
Wir haben uns schon so oft weggeschmissen bei dem Teil.
Okay, gut, ich dank dir.
Weil, gleich gibt's wieder Kurz-Info.
Und mit Telefonen hier weiter. Ihr könnt anrufen unter 0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110 und Fragen stellen zum Thema Informationssuche im Internet. Keine Angst vor vermeintlich dumm fragen. Kann sein, dass wir hier wieder ein bisschen zu schnell sind. Also wenn ihr einfach sagt, ich verstehe das überhaupt nicht, wie ich anfange, irgendwas zu suchen, rote einfach hier an, wir versuchen es zu erklären. Die Musik kommt heute nach wie vor von Sending Out Signals und das ist keine Band, sondern das sind die beiden DJs, die hier stehen am Pult und live auflegen. Was da genau läuft, können wir euch nicht explizit sagen, weil das teilweise auch gar nicht im Verkauf erhältliche Sachen sind und so weiter. Deswegen bei dem Titel vorhin hat es ja geklappt. Ansonsten, wenn ihr ganz bestimmte Anfragen an die DJs habt, schickt mir Mail an chaos.org.de und wir leiten das weiter. Das ist auch die Mail-Adresse, die generell für diese Sendung gilt. Das lesen alle an der Sendung hier beteiligten Menschen.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
23.31 Uhr.
Streit, die ausländerpolitischen Beschlüsse der CSU haben am Abend zu einer heftigen Debatte im Bundestag geführt. Die Opposition kritisierte, die jüngsten Beschlüsse der Unionspartei schürten Rassismus. Innenminister Kanter CDU verteidigte dagegen die Forderung nach einem schärferen Ausländerrecht. Abstimmung. Umweltministerin Merkel bleibt im Amt. Die Bündnisgrünen scheiterten im Bundestag mit einem Antrag, in dem die CDU-Politikerin zum Rücktritt aufgefordert wurde. Hintergrund ist die Affäre um die verstrahlten Atommülltransporte. Ziele. Nordrhein-Westfalens neuer Ministerpräsident Wolfgang Clement SPD will versuchen, die Arbeitslosigkeit zu verringern. Außerdem will die rot-grüne Regierung dafür sorgen, dass junge Leute einen Ausbildungsplatz finden. Der Landtag in Düsseldorf hatte den bisherigen Wirtschaftsminister Clement heute zum Nachfolger von Johannes Rau gewählt. Wirkung. In Nordkorea konnte die Hungersnot durch Hilfslieferungen eingedämmt werden. Nach Angaben der Vereinten Nationen ist die Lage aber weiter dramatisch.
Sport.
Fußball in einem WM-Testspiel in Helsinki trennten sich Deutschland und Finnland null zu null.
Wetter.
Abends Schauer und Gewitter, nachts aufgelockert, 12 bis 9 Grad. Morgen wird es aber freundlich und warm, bis 29 Grad.
Verkehr.
A100 Wedding Richtung Tempelhof, Vollsperrung der Abfahrt, Kurfürstendamm wegen Bauarbeiten und das Ganze bis 4 Uhr.
Falk Zilke mit einem Fritz Kossin vor.
Fritz präsentiert bittersüße Symphonien, glückliche Männer und Drogen, die nicht arbeiten.
Live in Berlin, Mittwoch, 10.
Wir hören Chaosradio den Computer-Bloom-O-Moon jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat bei Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Johnny im Mikrofon und euch am Telefon, die wir auch gleich wieder ansprechen. Es geht um Informationssuche und Finden im Internet. Was uns hier nicht ganz klar war bis jetzt, da wir alle ein bisschen zu alt sind und schon aus der Schule raus sind, ist, dass das Thema Hausarbeiten doch scheinbar ein wichtiges Thema im Internet ist, was hier im Chat nämlich ziemlich viel diskutiert wird. Es gibt die Geschichte von www.hausarbeiten.de Ein Schüler, der angefangen hat, alle geschriebenen Hausaufgaben seiner Mitschüler und Mitschülerin einfach zu sammeln, ins Netz zu stellen. Und dann konnte man das halt nach bestimmten Themen suchen. Und das hat sich so rasant entwickelt, dass innerhalb von zwei Jahren da jetzt ganze Sammlungen von Hausarbeiten zu finden sind, aus ganz Deutschland. Das heißt, wenn man eine Hausaufgabe auf hat zu einem bestimmten Thema, dann kann man da nach Stichworten suchen und kann sich dann die nettesten Passagen selber zusammenstellen. Das ist natürlich nicht das, wofür ihr eigentlich lernt. Ihr lernt ja fürs Leben und so weiter und so fort. Hallo, wer ist denn da dran? Marco, hallo.
Ich hab eigentlich nichts anderes zu sagen.
Hast du in der letzten halben Stunde auch zugehört, was wir gesagt haben?
Äh, ja schon, klar.
Was da für einzelne Bands und Projekte laufen, können wir wirklich hier einfach nicht durchgehen. Das sind super unterschiedliche Sachen und die Jungs legen halt auf. Und da musste mal, wir können ja nachher mal ein paar Läden durchgeben, in Berlin zumindest, wo man so ein Zeug kriegt. Ja, dann kann man sich da ein bisschen hinstellen, ein paar Sachen anhören und geben wir euch gleich ein paar Tipps noch. So, denkt ihr da mit dran, dass wir das wirklich machen?
Nicht, dass ich den wieder vergesse.
So, aber Thema Suchmaschinen, hallo.
Ja, ich wollte mal zum Thema Hausaufgaben zusammen was einwerfen. Es gibt ja auch eine Seite, die heißt Homeworksnet. Die bieten sogar Kosten für Nachhilfe. Manche Seiten, die können jetzt mittlerweile, so wie Abituts.de oder so was aus Ruhe kommen, die führen dann ein ganzes Verteidnis in Deutschland, wo es überall Nachhilfelehrer so extern gibt. Bei Homeworksnet, also Homeworks mit X geschrieben, bieten sie in fünf oder sieben Fächern Nachhilfekosten nur zwei E-Mail an. Also richtig mit echten Lehrern dann. Wenn man konkrete Fragen hat oder selber einfach nicht fündig wird im Netz, weil man sich oft zu doof anstellt in Suchmaschinen, dann kann man sich da direkt dranwenden. Dann hab ich noch mal eine Frage zum Hacken. Ich hör das oft, dass Leute, wie zum Beispiel am Anfang erzählt wurde, die einfach an vier Rechnern sitzen und dann drauf loshacken, würde mich ja tierisch interessieren, wie die da eigentlich anfangen. Und das finde ich im Internet nie so richtig, weil ich auch gar nicht weiß, wo ich die Nachricht genauer suchen soll. Hauptsächlich findet man englische Sachen, bis man die immer halbwegs verstanden hat. Ich bin ja auch nur in deutscher und kann nicht so berauschend englisch. Da findet man nichts. Da braucht es immer so lange, bis man sortiert und die Telefonrechnung stärkt und stärkt. Mich interessiert es nicht so, dass ich selber tierisch rumhacken will. Nur mehr zum Testen der eigenen Seiten. Mich würde auch interessieren, wie du das aufstellen solltest vom eigenen Terror wäre.
Diese Informationen liegen natürlich alle im Internet. Sie sind vollständig da, diese Informationen zu finden. Das hat natürlich auch ein bisschen was mit dem eigenen Bildungsstand zu tun. Nicht mit dem, was in die Wiege gelegt wurde, sondern wie weit man sich einfach in die Materie vorwagt. Diese Frage, ich würde ja auch ganz gerne mal hacken, die kriegen wir irgendwie 20 Mal pro Woche per E-Mail. Wir verweisen da immer auf unsere FAQs. Das möchte ich jetzt gerne auch mal tun. Unter www.ccc.de slash FAQ.html haben wir sozusagen die am häufigsten gestellten Fragen zusammengetragen. Da gibt es auch einen schönen Verweis auf ein Hacker-How-To. Wie lerne ich hacken? Da solltest du auf jeden Fall mal reinschauen, wenn dich das interessiert. Weil dabei auch klar sein sollte, dass es sich bei Hacken eher um eine Geisteshaltung handelt, als um eine technische Sportart.
Wobei ich glaube, inzwischen alles, vielleicht gibt es in ein paar Jahren dann irgendwie, kannst du eine Ausbildung machen als Hacker, irgendwie drei Jahre an einem Institut.
Kann man leider heute schon mal...
Kannst du jetzt schon mal der US Army machen, ja.
Ach, erstaunlich, siehst du, was ich wieder alles nicht weiß.
Naja, es gibt halt schon ein paar Zeiten im Netz, wo man halt irgendwie die gängigen Exploits findet, also die Fehler im Betriebssystem, die man halt ausnutzen kann, bloß ohne ein gewisses Grundwissen darüber, wie halt Betriebssysteme funktionieren, wie das Netz funktioniert, wie TCP-IP funktioniert. Und all diese Dinge funktionieren, hilft jetzt natürlich auch nicht viel weiter. Und darum, dass irgendwie du Englisch lernen musst, um diese Dinge zu verstehen und lesen zu können, da wirst du einfach nicht drum rumkommen. Es gibt einfach niemand, der sich irgendwie die Mühe macht, diese ganzen Informationen ins Deutschland zu übersetzen.
Mehr oder weniger, um Informatikstudien kommen wir auch nicht drum herum. Also so vorne sich einfach Spaß mit zu beschäftigen und dann mal zu sehen, ob es eigentlich Spaß macht, ob es sich dann lohnt, Informatik zu studieren, weil man wirklich noch mehr Interesse hat, dann kommt man irgendwie nicht dazu.
Also hat hier jemand Informatik studiert?
Also die meisten guten Hacker sind übrigens abgebrochen, Informatik-Studenten.
Ich sag das nochmal viel härter, die Informatiker taugen nach meiner Ansicht in der Regel nichts, weil man an der Uni eine bestimmte Lernhaltung einfach ausgetrieben kriegt. Und ich mach gerade im Moment in der Entwicklung, was ich so tut, bestimmte alte Tugenden, die vor 20 Jahren gefragt waren, also so Platz halten mit umgehen, effektiv programmieren, die sind im Moment wieder gefragt, weil die ganzen Anwendungen, die jetzt in die Chipkarten reingepackt werden, da muss es möglichst billig sein und da muss man wieder sparsam programmieren. Und derartige Sachen, die lernt man nur, wenn man sich wirklich ins einzelne Bit reinfummelt und nicht irgendwie jetzt so die Überflieger-Nummer an der Uni mit Informatik macht.
Die Überflieger-Nummer, würde ich eher sagen, ist so Wirtschaftsinformatik, wo man hauptsächlich irgendwie, naja, die grafische Zeugung, die Ladenspräsentation zu erstellen, ein bisschen vielleicht noch mal Wirtschaft mit rein.
Also Wirtschaftsinformatik kannst du direkt vergessen. Muss ich dir mal ganz deutlich sagen. Hör dich mal rein, hör dich das halbe Semester an. Die Leute bieten so Schnupper an, da gehst du mal eine Woche hin, hörst dir das mal in Ruhe an und dann weißt du, dass du das nicht hören willst wahrscheinlich. Also es gibt Leute, ich hab mir das wahrscheinlich fein gemacht. Hörst dir an und wenn du da immer noch rein willst, dann geh rein.
Was andere wissen, Herr, ich mein so ein Computerbücher ist in der Aufschweine strah.
Also so ist es ja nicht, dass man da nicht rankäme oder man geht halt zum Laden und sich das da in Ruhe durch.
Bei der Uni hat man oft den Vorteil, dass man halt, wenn man etwas absolut nicht kapiert oder nicht weiß, dann sofort jemand fragen kann.
Alles, was du brauchst, ist Folgendes. So, dann gehst du irgendwie in ein Fachbuchladen deiner Wahl und kaufst dir eine Linux-CD und dann installierst du die Linux. Und dann machst du dir deinen Internetzugang klar und wenn du so weit schon mal bist, dann hast du deine ersten Erfolgsergebnisse schon mal am Start. Und wenn du dann irgendwelche Fragen hast, dann fragst du. Und dann suchst du die Informationen so, wie wir das jetzt gleich auch nochmal erklären werden, nämlich im Wesentlichen über Newsgroups und über Mail. Und fragst die Leute einfach selber. Wenn du heute irgendwie, gerade wenn du so mit Linux arbeitest und in eine Linux-Gemeinde hineinfragst, ich habe dieses und jenes Problem, dann kriegst du viel Hilfe. Denn es handelt sich hierbei um eine Gemeinschaft von Leuten, die da an einem Stand zieht und miteinander lernt. Lernen ist nicht irgendwie irgendwo hingehen und sich von irgendjemand irgendwas erzählen lassen, sondern lernen ist im Wesentlichen das selber ausprobieren. Und dann kannst du auch erst mal drei Jahre lang irgendwie mit dem Zahnfleisch auf dem Asphalt lang schleifen. Das macht alles nichts, weil das übt alles, das härtet einfach ab. Und dann wird das auch alles gut.
Hier kam noch mal die Anfrage der umgekehrte Weg. Sollten wir nachher auch noch mal drauf eingehen? Also wie sorge ich dafür, dass mein Notebook bei Page anständig in den Suchmaschinen auftaucht? Können wir nachher auch noch mal drauf eingehen? So, wer ist denn da? Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Das hat ja wieder erschreckt. Och, weißt du schon, wie ein Scheißdälen sagt auch nicht gleich Chaosradio.
Hallo, wer ist denn da? Matthias, hallo.
Na Jungs, ich war bei euch vor ein paar Wochen schon mal am Discordia.
Hast du uns zugehört oder hast du uns nicht zugehört?
Ich höre jetzt ungefähr so eine Stunde schon zu.
Hast du eine Frage?
Ach komm, also wenn du keine Frage hast, was ist das?
Nee, ich hab euch gefragt, wie weit ihr im Discordia schon seid.
Womit?
Mit den Computeranlagen und so.
Na ja, da stehen so diverseste Computer rum. Also wir haben irgendwie, glaube ich, mittlerweile 10 Maschinen am Start und kein einziger davon fällt Windows.
Na das ist ja auch in Ordnung so. Noch eine andere Sache, ich hab bei euch die Mitschnitte von den ganzen Sendungen auf dem Web gesehen und mit Erstaunen festgestellt, euer MP3-File ist ungefähr 150 MB groß.
Wie soll ich das runterladen?
Na ja, das ist im Wesentlichen für Leute, die so was mirren und auf CDs pressen. Wir wollten auch noch ein kleineres MP3-File machen, allein uns fehlte die Zeit. Aber es steht nach wie vor das ewige Commitment, dass wir das auch tun wollen. Aber wir müssen ja nebenbei auch noch ein bisschen leben und was schon, Geld verdienen und solche ekligen Sachen machen. Und da kommen wir leider nicht immer dazu, den 100%igen erstklassigen Service zu gewähren, wie ihr das vielleicht von großen, aus dem Geld von allen Steuerzahlern geförderten, nicht rechtlichen Fersen erstalten gewohnt seid.
Na nicht, dass ich es nach wie vor auch noch beschwert, weil das hängt ja glaube ich dran, ne?
Und wie hängt ja Bandbreite?
Ich glaube, die haben kein Problem mit Bandbreite.
Dann haut rein, verdienen noch ein bisschen Geld und wir werden sehen uns, ne?
Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaosradio.
Ja hallo, hier ist Philipp aus Brück. Ja, ich hab noch eine Frage zu den ganzen Newsgroups und Foren.
Philipp, hat dein Telefon irgendwie einen Wackeler oder so? Du kommst immer so unterbrochen an.
Schalt mal den Rasierapparat aus.
Gar nicht so einfach, ne? Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, ob ich richtig verstanden habe, was du gefragt hast. Also es ging um Newsgroup und Adressen? Kannst du das vielleicht noch etwas konkretisieren? Wenn du den Rasierapparat gefunden hast.
Was hast denn da jetzt abgeschaltet?
Irgendwie hat er jetzt die Spielkonsole an und den Rasierapparat ausgeschaltet.
Gut, jetzt haben wir die Vorhalsversuche.
Was hast du jetzt noch?
Also folgendes, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Probleme beim PC auftauchen und irgendwelche Newsgroups, in denen man natürlich die wie immer fragen kann oder so was, dann bei T-Online da hat man nur, kriegt man immer blöde Antworten, wenn man irgendwas falsches fragt.
Was meinst du mit bei T-Online?
Weil T-Online ist keine Newsgroups, sondern ein Internet-Service Provider.
Ja, also deine Frage ist eigentlich, wo findest du bestimmte Newsgroups?
Ja, lass mich mal direkt drauf antworten. Eine ganz wichtige Sache ist die newsgroup.de.newusers.infos. Da wird unter anderem regelmäßig die Liste aller deutschsprachigen Newsgruppen und wofür die gedacht sind gepostet. Und wenn man die mal so durchschaut, was da alles drin steht, dann findet man eigentlich schon ziemlich schnell diejenige, die vom Namen und von der Bedeutung hier richtig ist. Und falls man keine findet, gibt es da noch die zweite. Das ist de-User-Questions. Also jetzt, das hat sich so historisch entwickelt, dass das wohl deutschsprachig ist, da den englischen Namen hat. Und da gab es lange Diskussionen darüber, ob man das nun umbenennt. Aber man hat es so gelassen. Und da ist ein Haufen hilfreicher deutschsprachiger Leute, die versuchen mit einer Menge Humor, die banalsten Fragen effektiv zu antworten. Es gibt auch immer ein paar dabei, die da also irgendwie mit einer etwas myrerischen Art drin sind. Damit muss man eben auch leben. Aber es hat jeder, jeder hat mal angefangen. Und von daher sind ausgerechnet in DEU User Questions eine Reihe hoch erfahrener Menschen, die sich bemühen, eben die banalsten Fragen zu beantworten. Und eben selber auch daraus lernen, ihre eigenen Dienste, diese an irgendwelchen Servern, an der Uni, Bibliothek, Wien oder sonst wo machen, selber zu verbessern. Und da wird man dann in die richtige Richtung geschickt in der Regel. Also wo einem dann auch wirklich geholfen wird.
Ja, naja, und mit diesen ganzen Sub-Maschinen hat man ja zum Beispiel ein zusammengesetztes Wort, wie soll man das dann machen? Schreibt man das mit Komma oder Bindestrichen?
Mehrere Versuche empfehle ich da. Und da jetzt dann gleich nochmal auf eine Suchmaschine für die Newsgruppen, also jetzt gerade zu Computerfragen, ist die nach meiner Erfahrung effektivste Suchmaschine für Newsgruppen Deja News. Also http://www.dejanews.com Und wenn man da gleich im kompletten Archiv sucht, mit ein paar Stichworten zum Problem, mein wegen irgendwie Soundkarte, den Typennamen dahinter, dann kriegt man in der Regel so viele Antworten, oder so viele Artikel zu dem Thema, dass man erstmal überlegen muss, was nimmt man noch für einen Begriff dazu, damit es weniger werden und man es genauer rausfindet. Und wenn man das macht, hat man in der Regel schon die Antwort gefunden, denn gerade bei Computerproblemen, das Zeug wird ja in solchen Stückzahlen gemacht, dass eigentlich immer viele Leute die gleichen Probleme haben.
Ich hab hier auf meinem Computer einen Bildschirm schon installiert und der hat gleich eine ganze Bibliotheksdatei mit runtergezogen.
Ich glaube, das machen wir in der Sendung.
Ja, dann musst du ein Linux installieren.
Dann passiert das nicht mehr.
Keine Windows-Fragen, bitte.
Dann musst du dich selber zu einer Suchmaschine bewegen und die Frage dort bearbeiten lassen.
Dann kannst du dich im Netz beschimpfen lassen.
Gut, danke erstmal.
Das ist überhaupt mit den Newsgroups ein wichtiger Tipp. Also, besorgt mal nicht nur durchs WWW, sondern beschäftigt euch mit Newsgroups. Das ist eigentlich ein riesiges schwarzes Brett mit tausend verschiedenen Oberthemen, in denen sich Leute nur zu diesem einen ganz speziellen, diese Themen werden immer spezieller, zu einzelnen Themen unterhalten. Da gibt es auch sehr viele deutschsprachige Newsgroups. Und das ist sowieso ein genereller Tipp fürs Internet, was eben nicht Fernsehen in etwas anderer Form ist. Also das heißt, man guckt nur und kommuniziert nur, sondern man muss kommunizieren und nicht nur... Man, was ist denn das? Konsumieren, genau. Nicht nur konsumieren, sondern kommunizieren. Und unterhaltet euch mit Leuten zu dem Thema. Und dann klappt das auch alles. Und dann kriegt man auch die Information. Weil ich kriege diese ganzen Mails, wo Leute schreiben, schick mir doch mal was über die Foo Fighters. Wann haben die Sex-Pistols sich aufgelöst? Ich bin keine Suchmaschine. Also durchforstet das Netz, benutzt die Suchmaschinen. Und wie, das werden wir jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter erklären.
Sehr wichtig fand ich jetzt diesen Ausrät auf die News Groups. Und dass man nämlich da eigentlich am effektivsten finden kann. Ein Beispiel, ich habe darüber nachgedacht, ich habe es letztlich nicht gemacht, aber ich habe darüber nachgedacht, mir eine ISDN-TK-Anlage zu kaufen und ein kleines Gerät. Und ich wusste etwa, ich wollte das und das und das Feature haben. Dann habe ich meinen News-Rider genommen und bin die Liste von den News Groups, die auf dem News Server, den ich benutze, so vorhanden sind. Und da gibt es ein de.com.isdn.ek-Anlage.
So, wunderbar.
Hab mir die News Group genommen, hab mir Artikel geschrieben und hab gesagt, ja Jungs, ich brauch irgendwie eine TK-Anlage. Die muss das und das und das können, muss irgendwie 2S0-Ports haben und noch ein paar analoge und tralala und Vermittlungsstellen-Funktionen brauche ich nicht. Und die darf nicht wackelig sein, darf kein scheiß Plastik sein und dieses und jenes. Dann habe ich innerhalb von drei Tagen 5 Mails bekommen, die mir ganz konkret auf bestimmte Produkte hingewiesen haben, ich hätte eigentlich nur noch mit diesen ausgedruckten Mails unterm Arm in den Laden laufen müssen und hätte mir das Passende gekauft. Und der Overhead war einfach Null. Ich habe irgendwie 30, 50 Zeichen ASCII in das Netz gegossen und habe irgendwie 150 Zeichen zurückbekommen und der Verlust war einfach gleich Null. Das war einfach alles von Wert. Schneller kann man irgendwie eine Information nicht finden.
Aber der entscheidende Punkt dabei ist, du hast eben eine präzise Frage gestellt, weil du wusstest, was du wolltest.
Darauf wollte ich ja hinaus. Man kann in den News Groups sehr genau auf eine bestimmte Sache allein schon durch die Wahl der Gruppe gehen.
Man sollte sich sowieso darin schulen, zu wissen, was man will. Das ist irgendwie gar kein schlechter Tipp. Ich meine, einfach nur surfen und durch Zufall Sachen finden, das ist ja auch nett, macht halt Spaß, ist ein Zeitvertreib usw. Aber wenn man wirklich gezielt sucht, sind die News Groups wirklich ein guter Einstieg. Also habe ich auch sehr, sehr gute Erfahrungen. Und das ist vor allem super nett, weil du kriegst, also manchmal bleiben dann auch Kontakte von Leuten, wenn du auf einmal merkst, du hast dieselben Interessen usw. Das ist echt eine sehr nette Geschichte.
Ja, sehr abhängig von der News Group. Also wirklich sehr abhängig von der News Group. Auf Mailinglisten ist es eigentlich noch viel intimer und viel besser. Mailinglisten ist ja auch noch so ein Thema. Mailinglisten sind ja sozusagen die Alternative zur News. Ohne halt irgendwie die Nachteile von News. Weil man halt dadurch, dass man Mailinglisten viel besser moderieren kann als News Groups, den ganzen letzten Spam loswerden kann, weil die Leute sich besser kennen und vor allen Dingen, wenn man weiß, wer Lied mitliest. Also Mailinglisten sind ja sozusagen geschlossene Benutzergruppen des Internets, wo man halt, also es gibt natürlich offene und geschlossene dabei, wie üblich, wo man sich sehr detailliert über bestimmte Themen unterhalten kann. Man kann halt die Mails, das hört man auch normalerweise im Archiv in seinem Mailing-Mail-Reder, und kann sie halt durchsuchen und durchforsten und all diese Dinge. Also ich bevorzuge mittlerweile doch deutlich Mailinglisten gegen News Groups.
Genau, wobei die Mailinglisten eigentlich noch am schwierigsten zu finden sind.
Also zunächst einmal, mir ist keine Webmaschine bekannt, es gibt ein deutsches sprachiges Verzeichnis der offenen Mailinglisten.
Tatsache, na gut, wo ist das, weißt du auch nicht.
Nutzfragen.
Plus Mailingliste plus Deutsch plus Verzeichnis.
Genau, also eine Mailingliste ist halt etwas, wo man sich einträgt, wo man in dem Moment, wo man an diese Mailadresse eine Mail schickt, eben alle Leute, die sich dort auch eingetragen haben, erreicht. Dadurch hat man eben einen sehr freiwilligen Kreis erreicht, mit dem Ergebnis, dass man eben auch nicht so viel Flames bekommt, also nicht gleich die Leute irgendwie total durchdrehen. Wir haben zum Beispiel hier in unserer eigenen Hausmitteilungs-Newsgroup de.org.ccc, die da eben auch noch interne Mailinglisten gibt, nicht unbedingt im Wesentlichen von CCC-Mitgliedern benutzt wird, um untereinander Kommunikation zu betreiben. Das ist halt recht offen und wird dann auch gerne von vielen als der Ort, wo man jetzt an die Hacker-Informationen rankommt. Und jedes Kit brüstet sich da irgendwie immer breit mit irgendwelchem Kram. Und da wird einfach unglaublich viel geflamet. Das will man natürlich auch nicht besonders gerne, aber da kann man auch nicht sehr viel gegen machen.
Aber ich habe dort auch eine ganze Menge exzellenter Informationen gefunden. Und auch so die Homepages, die dort angegeben sind. Da ist so meine Strategie. Ich gehe als erstes auf eine mir unbekannte Homepage. Und da auf die Seite, wo andere links sind. Weil das ist üblicherweise derjenige, der sich da so eine Homepage bastelt. Der bastelt sich auch eine Struktur zusammen, wo er jetzt so quasi seine Bookmarks als öffentliche Liste. Und über die Wege habe ich schon eine ganze Menge von Sachen gefunden, die ich vorher einfach noch nicht kannte und wo ich dachte, oh, das ist aber praktisch und das ist ein kurzer Weg.
Bleiben wir dran. Wir reden jetzt nämlich erstmal ein bisschen über die Musik. Mit Sending Out Signet, zumindest mit einer Hälfte davon. So, jetzt kommt unheimlich viel Anfragen nach der Musik, unter anderem auch im Chat und per Telefon. Und ich sag immer, das machen die DJs. Ich weiß nicht, was sie da auflegen.
Was legt sie denn da auf?
Ja, es hat eigentlich keinen genauen Namen. Es steht in der Elektro-Ecke eigentlich, ist aber eigentlich kein Elektro.
Ist das eine konkrete Aussage, Marc?
Ja, das ist das Problem. Man hat immer das Problem, wenn man im Plattenladen geht, irgendwie, die verstehen mich nie, was ich haben will. Man muss sich das leider wirklich selber raussuchen. Wie gesagt, es steht irgendwie zum Teil unter Technos, es sind irgendwelche Tracks von irgendwelchen Techno-Platten, wo einfach irgendwie ein Remix oder so drauf ist. Und ja, suchen, ganz viel suchen.
Da sind wir dann wieder beim Thema Suchmaschinen. Wie man nämlich bestimmte Musik in Platten läden findet, ist eigentlich ein ähnliches Problem. Mir genauer, man weiß, was man will, desto besser findet man es natürlich auch. Also prinzipiell geht es natürlich um elektronische Musik, das hört man ja auch. Und da kann man auch in die großen Ketten gehen, die er auch...
Ja klar, also WOM hat leider, leider ein ganz gutes Angebot, obwohl ich eigentlich WOM-Bockettier. Wo man noch hingehen könnte, wenn man Platten, also Vinyl kaufen möchte, ist Hardwax in Berlin, auf der linken Ufer. Das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter Laden. Auch eine sehr nette Bedienung, hat einmal einen Lob verdient. Hat leider praktisch überhaupt keine CDs.
Was denn?
Ja, wir legen die CDs auch.
Ich meine, gut, ihr habt hier zwei DJ-CD-Player stehen, aber die meisten DJs arbeiten doch mit Vinyl, oder? Das ist im Elektrobereich anders.
Nee, es ist eigentlich nicht anders. Aber gerade wenn jetzt Leute nach Musik fragen, ist es eigentlich so, dass viele Leute zu Hause nur noch einen CD-Player haben und keine Platten mehr.
Also Hardworks, Paulinke Ufer ist eine Empfehlung, Laden mit Traditionen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und dann gibt es noch Nevergreen in Friedrichshain, da habe ich leider keine genaue Adresse, hat sehr viele CDs. Dann gibt es noch die Space Hall in Zorsen-Alzberg, Zorsener Straße, ist eigentlich auch ganz gut sortiert.
Direkt gegenüber ist noch Raw.
Ja, geht auch, ist auch okay. Und ja, ich bin eigentlich von Berlin auch ein bisschen enttäuscht, was die Plattenlehnen anbelangt. Ich komme eigentlich aus Hamburg und Berlin fand ich ein bisschen enttäuschend.
Sollen wir in Berlin, in Hamburg?
Also in Hamburg gibt es eigentlich praktisch nur noch einen Laden. Also der Container ist gestorben, es verfrühr eigentlich so die Adresse. Der Mensch, der da den Einkauf organisiert hat, hat selbst einen Laden aufgemacht, namens Utaku in der Feldstraße und der hat einfach ganz ganz ganz großes Lob verdient. Also der ist wirklich fähig und der versteht einen auch, wenn man sagt, das und das möchte ich haben. Sehr bemüht, also großes Lob.
Plattenlehnen sind ja auch immer so eine eingeschworene Gemeinschaft und auch so ein Problem, gerade wenn man irgendwie da reingeht und sagt, also ich habe da neulich was gehört und so in der Richtung und es macht blieb und tüt und es ist ungefähr so schnell oder so, dann ist man natürlich schnell als mich richtig fachkundig verschrien und dann wird man oft mal ein bisschen komisch angeguckt am Plattenlehnen.
Ja, ich generell bin blöd angeguckt.
Das gehört einfach dazu. Ich habe selber jahrelange Plattenladenerfahrungen hinter mir, also als Verkäufer und als Plattenverkäufer ist man einfach ein Arschloch. Das ist einfach so, das gehört dazu und das muss man sein und davon darf man sich als Kunde einfach überhaupt nicht beeindrucken lassen. Man hat einfach in einem Plattenladen als Verkäufer nichts zu tun und deswegen vertreibt man sich die Zeit mit Arschloch sein. Entschuldigung, alle Plattenverkäufer sind hier. Ich habe mal in einer etwas größeren Kette, die es in Berlin nicht mehr gibt, gearbeitet. Jahre lang und da war es einfach so, dass man nach einer Weile...
Ach du warst auch mal Arschloch.
Ja, in der Beziehung schon. Muss leider zugeben. Also das waren ein paar Sätze zur Musik. Und ansonsten einfach zuhören und vielleicht einfach im Plattenleben gehen und einfach öfter mal Platten rausziehen, von dem man überhaupt keine Ahnung hat, was es eigentlich ist. Einfach mal reinhören bei den Läden, wo das noch geht. Vielleicht dann in den Zeiten in die Läden gehen, wo man weiß, dass es nicht ganz so voll ist und dann kann man sich ein paar Sachen empfehlen lassen. Weil eigentlich sind nämlich Plattenverkäufer und wären dann immer nett, wenn sie merken, dass man sich einfach für Musik begeistert und für Musik interessiert.
Das stimmt.
Und nicht nur halt dieses eine Lied will, was da in der Werbung läuft. Felix, was ist deine Lieblingsplatte zurzeit?
Naja, ich rechte nicht mehr in Platten, sondern in MPEG.
Dein Lieblingsdatei?
Dein Lieblings MPEG 3? Ach, immer noch?
Ja, immer noch.
Ich hab neulich mit MPEG 3 übrigens eine witzige Geschichte erlebt, weil ich hab einen bestimmten Song, ich sag jetzt mal nicht worum es geht, weil es natürlich alles ganz illegal ist, wobei ich mich natürlich legal verhalten hab, aber einen bestimmten Song, den ich sehr mag und ich hatte den nicht auf CD und ich hab den in ein paar Plattenlähnen immer so, das gibt's halt nur als Single, gibt's noch nicht, aber es ist kein Albumtrack. Die Leute, die diesen Song haben und Singles sind da in Plattenlähnen nicht immer so richtig vorhanden, die gibt's dann mal kurz und dann sind sie wieder weg und wenn es nicht eine absolute Neuheit ist, jedenfalls hab ich diesen verdammten Track nicht mehr bekommen. Ja, und dann muss man halt ins Netz gehen und da hab ich den bekommen und dann gibt's mir die Discord. Das ist doch echt, echt schlimm, oder? Dann hab ich ihn natürlich gleich wieder gelöscht.
Eine kleine Anmerkung zur MP3 übrigens, auf berlin.ccc.de haben wir vorhin, also hat Hans vorhin einen MPEG-Encoder im Source abgelodelt, der momentan eigentlich alles ausperformt, was ich so sonst gesehen hab.
Achtherz oder was?
Ne, nicht den Achtherz, den gibt's nicht im Quellcode, aber es hat jemand die freien Saucen genommen und soweit optimiert, dass die auf einer 500 MHz einfach in 110 Prozent der Abspielzeit entkoden können, also fast Spieltime. Und das Teil gibt's halt, es gibt Force Code und ist glaube ich sogar GPL und liegt halt in Flash Pub, Flash Misc auf berlin.cc.de und das lässt sich sogar mit dem Cygnus-Port von GNU-C unter NT kompilen und also... Genau.
Nicht, dass ich was Stuppen verstanden habe.
Für die private Back-up-Sammlung der CDs.
Für die reine Artilierung meinst du. Ist klar.
Na das bringt uns zu Billes wieder auf den Punkt, nochmal auf unsere kleinen Webseiten und FDP-Server hinzuweisen. www.ccc.de ist häufig schon genannt worden. Für die Sendung gibt's halt dann auch den Server Chaosradio.ccc.de, wo dann auch die Mitschnitte zu finden sind, wie auch auf dem Fritz Archiv, wo sie immer in Re-Audio vorliegen und wir bemühen uns das irgendwie auch in MPEG zu machen und sicherlich auch mal in etwas kleineren Pfeildimensionen als 150 MB. Allerdings werden wir auch immer die Großen noch mit draufpacken. Einfach weil wir eben auch möchten, dass die Musik auch erhalten wird, weil hier geht's eben auch nicht nur ums Labern, sondern geht's ja auch ein bisschen ums Erleben.
Ansonsten, E-Mail-Adresse von uns hier ist chaos.orb.de, das haben wir auch schon ein paar mal erwähnt und wir werden jetzt nicht, wie im Chat angefragt, mehr über MPEG 3 reden, weil hatten wir das schon mal das Thema? Nicht als solches.
Suchmaschine nehmen, nachlesen, forschen.
Es gibt natürlich auch Suchmaschinen, die speziell für MPEG 3...
Da können wir sowieso mal drauf eingehen auf spezielle Suchmaschinen. Denn zum Beispiel, wir haben schon von Deja News geredet, dass man da nach bestimmten Themen, das kann man natürlich mit jedem News Group-Client auch machen, aber wenn man nur an Deja News ist, 95 zurück. Okay, also dann da bis 95 zurück, da kann man auf ein Archiv zugreifen.
Und Felix ist, der heute Abend in der Telefonleitung ist, der hat in der Deja Org CCC die zweite archivierte Meldung geschrieben. Das haben wir heute beim Suchen gefunden.
Wir waren echt belustigt.
Wir haben einfach mal nach und gesucht, was eine ziemlich sichere Methode ist, um eine deutsche Information zu finden. Also, wenn ihr was Deutsches sucht, dann sucht nicht nach plus Deutsch oder sowas. Sucht einfach unter anderem auch noch nach und. Das findet sich einfach in englischen Mitteilungen relativ selten und ist für Deutsche doch relativ.
Das ist das zweitholchigste Wort. Das häufigste Wort ist die und das heißt irgendwie das oder die. Das gibt es auch in Englischen.
So, spezielle Suchmaschinen. Was gibt es denn noch für spezielle Suchmaschinen? Also es gibt zum Beispiel, wer macht das? Ich glaube Infoseek macht das, dass man nach Bildern und Tönen aussuchen kann. Das funktioniert nicht so richtig toll, aber manchmal, also muss man ein bisschen ausprobieren.
Wie macht man das? Man muss dir der Blumaschina was vorsingen?
Du könnt diese Ersut einfach nach Dateien haben.
Nein, was er macht, ist, dass er den Text, der in HTML Seiten um ein Bild herum ist, als Beschreibung des Bildes wertet und das kann er nicht.
Das kann zu Katastrophen führen.
Das kann man ihm auch nicht anlassen, das ist ein ungelöstes Problem. Es gibt da wunderbare Papers, die stellen sich so vor, dass man ein Paint-Programm so ungefähr malt und der sucht ein ähnliches Bild drauf. Aber solange nicht klar ist, wie man der Suchmaschine sagen kann, wonach man jetzt genau sucht, also erwartet nicht viel, auch in den nächsten Jahren nicht.
Gibt es da nicht die Möglichkeit mit Metatext im HTML klare Hinweise für Suchmaschinen zu liefern?
Wenn das alles benutzt wird. Ich habe mal darüber gelästert, dass der Bill Gates versucht hat, eine neue Weltsprache zu schaffen. Diese Weltsprache hat den Namen Dos Paranto und besteht aus Wörtern mit maximal acht Buchstaben Länge. Und das ist ein Stück weit das Problem beim Suchen.
Felix, trotzdem noch mal die Frage mit dem Metatext.
Ja, diese Texte gibt es natürlich. Aber das Problem ist eben, wenn man ein Bild so beschreiben will, dass wirklich jeder das Bild finden kann. Wenn er eben die Suchanfragen stellt, dann beschreibt man eben auch, dass da ein Alchohlenchen in der Ecke sitzt und kleine Details. Und dann wird eben das Metatext richtig groß. Und wenn Metatext richtig groß wird, dann guckt sich eine Suchmaschine das an und denkt sich, ja, das ist bestimmt ein Pornotyp und der möchte mir jetzt hier 1000 Wörter reindrücken und ignoriert das.
Das ist auch...
Und dann schlägt sich mal wieder der gut gemeinte, irgendwie gut gemeinte Sache wieder selber.
Man muss auch mal dazu sagen, dass es natürlich auch vollkommen... Also der Aufwand, wenn man selber eine Website oder sogar mehrere betreut, da wirklich jedes Bild irgendwie in Metatext zu indexieren, ist natürlich absoluter Wahnsinn. Also...
Also es gab auch richtig gute Definitionen von den Leuten, die HTML definieren, das B3C-Konsortium. Die haben sich mal hingesetzt und haben definiert, man soll doch bitte oben in die Webseiten reinschreiben, wer der Autor ist und so. Generator, es gibt so ein paar definierte Standard-Text und die benutzt einfach wirklich keinen Schwein. Also Generator wird schon benutzt, nämlich von den Leuten, die es nicht besser wissen und sagen, wir Frontpage benutzen oder so. Und Microsoft Word, die tragen sich da eben ein oder Adobe PageMill. Und deswegen, das ist so eins der Text, die wird dann benutzt. Und wenn man dann jetzt beim Editor sagt, ich bin der Autor und mein Name ist, was weiß ich, Felix, dann trägt das halt Felix ein. Aber es ist niemand, das sagen wir mal, fast alle Sites, die so ein bisschen, die mindestens semi-professionell sind, machen eben ihre Webseiten nicht mit irgendwelchen Generatoren, sondern mit Templates, die irgendwie von Hand geschrieben wurden und die tragen da eben keine Metatext ein. Und das kann man im Grunde auch nicht erwarten, weil nehmen wir an, ich bin jetzt in der Zeitung und habe jeden Tag ein komplettes Update zu machen, mit, weiß ich nicht, ein Megabyte Taten kommen so zusammen pro Zeitung, mindestens. Und dann muss ich da jeweils einen Abstract formulieren, am besten noch automatisiert oder die wichtigen Wörter aussuchen, damit die in Metatext stehen. Also das ist nicht zumutbar.
Ja, wobei, du musst ja nicht jedes Thema als Zeitung irgendwie da drin in Metatext haben, aber zumindest...
Nein, aber man möchte doch haben im Grunde, man möchte doch den Suchmaschinen die Arbeit erleichtern, indem man ein kleines Abstract liefert, was sagen wir, zwei Zeilen lang ist, A-80-Zeichen und wo so repräsentativ drin steht, worum es geht in dem Artikel. So was würde man eigentlich haben wollen. Damit man, wenn jemand sucht nach einem Text über, dass er dann, also ein echtes Problem bei Suchmaschinen, was mir jetzt zum Beispiel begegnet ist bei meiner, ist, dass wenn man in Zeitungen nach Kohl sucht, dass man dann eben auch Artikel findet, wo steht, und der nächste Artikel handelt von Kohl hier weiter zum nächsten Artikel. Also sowas mit dem Inhalt überhaupt nichts zu tun hat. So ne Sachen finde ich dann eben auch, und das wäre doch die Sachen, die man eigentlich eliminieren wollen würde mit Meta-Tags. Dass man einfach den Leuten, die die Seiten machen, die Möglichkeit in die Hand gibt zu schreiben, also der relevante Teil von diesem Text ist so und so.
Das ist bei dpa-Meldungen doch schon so. Bei dpa-Meldungen sind grundsätzlich so geschrieben, dass man sich von hinten kürzen kann. Wenn man halt von irgendwie alles wegkürzt, außer die ersten drei Zahlen, ist es immer noch irgendwie eine Meldung, die zumindest irgendwie links am Rand in den drei Teilen stehen kann. Das ist eigentlich irgendwie ein relativ gutes Prinzip, nur dass man es leider nicht von allen Leuten verlangen kann.
Ja, das ist halt wirklich eine Frage. Also da liegt halt die Verantwortung bei den Autoren.
Ja, genau. Vielleicht kannst du noch mal kurz irgendwas zu Paperboy sagen, wenn du immer so anonym von deiner Suchmaschine sprichst.
Ja, ja genau. Also Paperboy ist eine Suchmaschine, die ich mal vor ungefähr einem Jahr jetzt angefangen habe zu schreiben. Und worum es da geht, ist, dass wir gesagt haben, Zeitungen, wenn man irgendwie aktuelle Nachrichten durchsuchen möchte, also nehmen wir an, ich hab im IRC gehört, der Pub ist erschossen worden und möchte jetzt doch mal nachgucken, dann kann ich entweder zu meiner Lieblingszeitung gehen und feststellen, steht da drin oder ich kann es halt nicht tun. Und dann hab ich eben verloren, kann zehn Zeitungen durchgucken und die Flut der Quellen nimmt einfach zu im Netz. Und deswegen haben wir uns gesagt, man braucht eine Spezial-Suchmaschine, die in Zeitungen suchen kann. Und sowas hab ich dann mal programmiert und die Anzahl der Quellen nimmt also explosionsartig zu. Angefangen haben wir mal mit zehn Quellen und dann haben wir auf 50 abgequältet, inzwischen sind es 288. Und das ist einfach ein Ausmaß, wo niemand mehr durchsuchen kann. Und der reguläre Search Engine hat eben das Problem, dass das Internet eigentlich ziemlich groß ist. Sobald man sich anhört, 30 Millionen URL. Und AltaVista hätte jetzt als Ziel, mindestens, also höchstens eine Woche veraltet zu sein. Also, dass sie nichts haben, was sich in der letzten Woche geändert hat, dass sie sowas mindestens mitkriegen. Dann müssten sie, kann man einfach ausrechnen, wie viele URLs sie sich angucken müssten pro Tag. Und das kann man eben, das ist schon rein rechnerisch, brüchen die dann eine Bandpreise, die ihre Leitung saturieren würde. Deswegen kann man von einer normalen Suchmaschine nicht erwarten, dass sie aktuell ist. Und deswegen ist einfach die Einschränkung auch geschickt zu sagen, wir machen eine Suchmaschine, die sich beschränkt auf ein relativ kleines Gebiet. Also 288 Quellen ist zwar viel, aber im Verhältnis zum Internet, es sind es Peanuts. Und das ist eben so, dass man dann sagen würde, so eine Suchmaschine kann dann aktuell sein. Und dann habe ich aber auch die Forderung als User, dass die Daten aktuell sind, und kann mich auch darauf verlassen und kann das benutzen als Informationsmedium wie eine Zeitung. Also das ist erstaunlich wichtig, weil viele große Firmen haben eine eigene Abteilung gegründet, die einfach nur Zeitungen lesen und gucken, ob da was drinsteht über sie, sowas zum Beispiel. Und das kann man als Privatperson nicht machen. Und das ist eben eine Sache, da kann das Internet eine Änderung bringen. Das ist wieder eine von den Sachen sowie das Erlebnis, wie was man hat, wenn man sich zum ersten Mal Zoom-Maschinen anguckt. Und da stellt man eben fest, dass ein Service dir sonst nicht möglich ist. Und man freut sich eben, wenn man sieht, es ist mir als Privatperson plötzlich in die Hand gegeben, da Sachen zu machen, die einfach vorher gar nicht denkbar waren. Und so einen Service, Sachen zu untersuchen, das ist eben auch für Privatpersonen sehr schön und dass der Service überhaupt möglich ist, ist eine Sache, die freut einfach. Und deswegen ist es wichtig, Spezial-Buchmaschinen überhaupt zu haben, nicht nur für Nachrichten jetzt, sondern auch für andere Sachen.
Dieses Suchproblem, ich sehe technologisch noch einen anderen Ansatz. Es gibt da auch ein passendes Protokoll. Ich bin allerdings selber nicht gerade im Bilde darüber, wie sich das entwickelt. Walz, sagt er ja sicherlich was? Jaja. Und das ist, wenn ich es richtig zusammenfasse, ein Protokoll, ein Suchtprotokoll für das Internet, wo man im Prinzip auf andere Suchserver, lokale Suchserver zugreift. Das heißt, jeder Informationsanbieter stellt seine Suchdienste weiß, kompatibel zur Verfügung, sodass ich sozusagen mehrere Suchmaschinen für mich gleichzeitig standardisiert suchen lassen kann. Womit die ganze Suchaktivität auf die lokalen Sites selber verlagert, wird ich aber trotzdem durch ein einziges Interface suche. Ist das nicht eigentlich das, was kommen wird?
Also man hat es gedacht und es sah auch am Anfang gar nicht schlecht aus, aber es ist ein Konsortiumstandard und das Problem ist, die Implementation, die es gab, war einfach absolut unperformant und scheiße und das hat sich auch keiner daran gehalten. Und wie das so ist mit Konsortiumstandard, das läuft am Ende so, dass man ein riesen Dokument hat, wo drin steht, diese drei Features sind wichtig und der Rest ist optional. Und dann gibt es halt 100 Implementationen und die implementieren total das Junge bis auf diese drei Moot-Features-Sachen und dann stellt sich heraus, dieses und jenes kann man gar nicht abbilden damit und dann gab es irgendwelche inkompatiblen kommerziellen Implementierungen und das ist also gescheitert. Der nächste Ansatz war, dass man es als ISO-Standard macht und da gibt es dann Z3950 heißt das glaube ich. Also es gibt auch ein anderes Protokoll, was auch für Großsuche gedacht ist. Und im Grunde ist das eine gute Sache, aber das Problem ist eben, da hält sich im Grunde niemand dran und sowas weiß auch fast keiner. Und im Grunde, wenn man sich überlegt, wenn ich jetzt eine Zeitung wäre, dann ist es mir wichtig, dass die Leute bei mir suchen können mit einem Dienst, den ich selber anbiete und es ist mir wichtig, dass die Leute in Alta Vista mich finden. Aber warum soll ich denn Geld dafür ausgeben, meine Sachen zu indizieren, irgendeine Software kaufen, irgendeinen kaufen, der sich damit auskennt, wenn Alta Vista das auch so macht. Also so sieht es aus für die Zeitung. Und deswegen ist der Ansatz zwar prinzipiell gut, aber ich sehe da keine Zukunft, ehrlich gesagt.
Felix, bleib mal noch dran, wir reden gleich bestimmt nochmal nach dem Fritzkurs einfach.
Bis gleich! Kontroverse. Die ausländerpolitischen Beschlüsse der CSU haben am Abend zu einer heftigen Debatte im Bundestag geführt. Die Opposition warf der CSU vor, Rassismus zu schüren. Innenminister Kanter, CDU, stellte sich hinter die Positionen der Schwesterpartei. Er verteidigte die Forderungen nach einem schärferen Ausländerrecht. Abstimmung. Umweltministerin Merkel bleibt trotz der Affäre um die verstrahlten Atommülltransporte im Amt. Die Bündnisgrünen konnten sich im Bundestag nicht mit ihrer Rücktrittsforderung durchsetzen. Die SPD enthielt sich der Stimme. Ziele. Nordrhein-Westfalens neuer Ministerpräsident Wolfgang Klement, SPD, will versuchen, die Arbeitslosigkeit zu verringern. Außerdem will die rot-grüne Regierung dafür sorgen, dass junge Leute einen Ausbildungsplatz finden. Der Landtag in Düsseldorf hatte den bisherigen Wirtschaftsminister Klement heute zum Nachfolger von Johannes Rau gewählt. Wirkung. In Nordkorea konnte die Hungersnot durch Hilfslieferungen eingedämmt werden. Nach Angaben der Vereinten Nationen ist die Lage aber weiter dramatisch. Fußball. In einem WM-Testspiel in Helsinki trennten sich Deutschland und Finnland null zu null.
Wetter.
Nachts aufgelockert, 12 bis 9 Grad. Tagsüber wird es aber freundlich und warm, bei Temperaturen bis zu 29 Grad.
Verkehr.
A100 Wedding Richtung Tempelhof, Vollsparrung der Abfahrt Kurfürstendamm wegen Bauarbeiten und das noch bis 4 Uhr.
Das war Falk Zielke mit dem Fritz Kurzinfo.
Ein No-You-Faults-Event. Classic Dance Tracks mit den DJs Namito und Marcos Lopez. Samstag, 30. Mai ab 23 Uhr in der Kalkscheune Berlin. Marcos Lopez hört ihr immer Freitags im Soundgarten.
Chaosradio geht in die letzten 20 Minuten. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat findet das Chaosradio bei Fritz statt. Ein spezieller Blumen, der sich um die Themen Computer und Kommunikation kümmert. Und zwar nicht unbedingt für Grundlagen, sondern schon ein bisschen für weitergehende Sachen. Heute reden wir über Suchmaschinen im Internet. Die Frage, wie finde ich eigentlich richtige Informationen im Internet? Ich hab eigentlich gedacht, dass andauernd Anfragen kommen werden. Also ich kriege hier über Fritz unglaublich viel mehr Mail von Leuten, die einfach wirklich nur fragen, wo finde ich dies und das? Und je nachdem, wie die Anfragen gestellt sind oder wie gerade meine Zeit aussieht, wenn ich am Mail machen bin, jeden Morgen, jeden Mittag, jeden Abend, dann sind die Antworten von mir mal mehr oder weniger patzig. Und meistens verweise ich aber doch auf Suchmaschinen und den Tipp, da einfach mal ein bisschen mit rumzuspielen. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob wir wirklich viel Licht ins Dunkel gebracht haben. Wir haben eigentlich auch im groben Zusammenfass gesagt, Suchmaschinen benutzen, aber das heißt noch lange nichts.
Na ja gut, wir haben auch gesagt, Newsgroups benutzen und Schlemmel-Listen benutzen. Und da würde ich ganz gerne noch mal drauf kommen, sich vor allem lernen mit dem Internet, sich mit den Leuten in Verbindung zu setzen. Das Ganze nicht immer wie so eine große Zeitung zu betrachten, sondern das Internet, das sind wir alle, die daran teilnehmen. Manche mehr, manche ein bisschen weniger, aber eine ganze Menge. Und vor allem die Leute, die wirklich Ahnung haben, fast durchgehend. So, also eigentlich alle Leute, die sich irgendwie ernsthaft mit Computern beschäftigen, die haben einfach täglichen Mailverkehr und können ja auch gar nicht. Ich muss mal Frank sehen, wenn der mal zwei Tage kein Internet hat. Das sind Junkies, nichts geben.
Es gibt doch immer noch keine körperlichen Inventuren.
Bist du sicher?
Zucken in den Schingern.
Doch, doch, da gibt es auch schon körperliche Inzuzine.
Ich hab vorhin kam auch im Chat die Anfrage, wie treffsicher eigentlich diese Mail-Adressen-Suchgeschichten sind. Das ist ja auch noch ein Thema, wenn ich jemanden, ich weiß nicht, ich hab jemanden seit ein paar Jahren nicht gesehen und denke, na, der oder die studiert doch und eigentlich müsste der oder die eine Internet-Adresse haben. Diese Trefferquoten hängen schwer von der Aktivität der einzelnen Leute im Netz ab. Also wenn jemand seinen Mail-Account, also seinen Internet-Anschluss, eigentlich nur zum E-Mail-Schreiben benutzt, dann findet man ihn in den seltensten Fällen über eine E-Mail-Adressen-Suchmaschine, was übrigens im Teilbereich der meisten Suchmaschinen ist. Wenn ich aber in Newsgroups poste, also da irgendwie auf Artikel antworte oder selber Fragen gestellt habe, oder wenn ich auf verschiedenen Web-Pages mit meinem richtigen Namen und der dazugehörigen Mail-Adresse eingetragen bin, dann sind die Trefferquoten relativ gut, habe ich festgestellt.
Na ja, es gibt halt so Leute, so Felix ist zum Beispiel so einer, der halt irgendwie ein echter News-Junkie ist, und da findet man auch wirklich die absurdesten Zitate. Ich habe ja gerade eins gefunden, echte Männer lesen nicht nur alles, diese lesen es auch laut und hören sich dabei modern Talking ein. Felix von Lightning D, Alt-Arno, was auch Hammer das sein will.
Arno ist schon eine ziemlich herbe Gruppe, wo, also das kann man nicht zu 100% ernst nehmen.
Felix, sag mal was dazu.
Die Talk-Bizarre ist eine ähnliche Richtung gewesen.
Ja, sowas finde ich aber toll.
Ja, natürlich, habe ich gerne geschrieben.
Felix, man kann im Chat übelen Nachrichten. Steht im Internet, ist wahr, kann es nichts mehr gegen tun.
Es gibt auch noch eine andere schöne.
Das kann ja gefakt sein. Kann ja sein, dass jemand unter seinem Namen gepostet hat.
Ich habe noch einen sehr guten Tipp. Und das kann man eigentlich gar nicht oft genug erwähnen, auch wenn ich es jetzt eigentlich das erste und vielleicht auch das einzige Mal erwähne. Es gibt eine tolle Sache für Fragen. Also all die Fragen, die man so hat, die haben vor allem eins an sich. Alle anderen fragen sie auch. Die meisten Fragen sind schon mal gefragt worden und vor allem sind sie alle schon mal beantwortet worden. Emsige Leute fassen solche Listen zusammen in einem FAQ. Frequently Asked Questions, häufig gestellte Fragen, fassen halt wunderbar zusammen eigentlich das, was der Neueinsteiger meistens fragen möchte. Zu welchen Themen auch immer, also zu allen möglichen Themen. Und da sind die News Groups auch ein wunderbarer Anspielort. Das heißt, wenn ihr für ein bestimmtes Thema euch interessiert, schaut nach, ob es da eine News Group gibt, die das Thema in etwa anschneidet. Den Aufbau von News Group-Namen brauch ich ja wohl nicht mehr so sehr viel zu sagen. Wenn ihr diese News Group gefunden habt, dann sucht ihr unter Umständen auch mit Suchmaschinen nach einem FAQ. Diese FAQs werden nicht selten regelmäßig auch in den News Groups gepostet, die liegen teilweise auf Archiven, wo auch der ganze Inhalt der News Groups, das ist auch noch sehr interessant, mitgeschrieben wird. Und man kann die dann auch über das Web eigentlich relativ zuverlässig finden. Das sind dann mehr oder weniger große ASCII-Dateien, wo im Frage-Antwort-Stil eben so die gängigen Themen behandelt werden. Also es gibt FAQs zum Wie mache ich mir meine eigenen Drogen? Wie baue ich meinen Motor in mein Auto? Wie fliege ich zum Mond? Und wie kann ich mich in der Galaxis bestatten lassen? Es gibt einen FAQ irgendwie bei unserem CCC-Webserver. Es gibt einen FAQ zu vielen sehr interessanten Dingen. Und einfach nach dem Thema und FAQ-Suchen halte ich für einen, der wirklich erfolgreich vorging, mit den größten Erfolgsaussichten.
Generell kann man eins wiederholen, was wir im Rahmen von Chaosradio auch schon ganz, ganz oft gesagt haben. Ich weiß, das ist eine der ersten Sachen, weil mir jemand gesagt hat, als ich angefangen habe, das Internet zu benutzen, viel, viel lesen. Erst viel lesen und dann fragen. Also wenn man zum Beispiel in einem Newsgroup zum ersten Mal, man kriegt ja dann diese Liste der letzten, weiß ich wie viel, 100 oder auch 1000 geposteten Artikeln, wenn man da zum ersten Mal reinguckt, es ist relativ unklever, obwohl man weiß, dass die Newsgroup sich um das gesuchte Thema dreht, es ist relativ unklever, da gleich reinzuspringen und, weiß ich nicht, drei Seiten dazu posten mit Fragen, sondern sehr clever ist es, erstmal ein bisschen zurück zu gucken, was sind gerade die Themen, die besprochen werden, und sehr einfach ist es auch einfach, ganz kurz, einfach die Frage zu stellen, wo bekomme ich das FAQ für diese Newsgroup, das wird gerne und schnell beantwortet, dann kann man sich das durchlesen, und ich glaube, wenn man erst mal so ein paar Dutzend Artikel da überflogen hat, man muss die nicht alle lesen, meistens steht in den Subject-Zeilen ja schon genug, worum sich es dreht, Dann weiß man ein bisschen, wie die Leute drauf sind. Dann sieht man, wer antwortet da sehr oft, wer antwortet mürrisch, wer antwortet nett und auch auf die Neueinsteigerfragen sehr gerne. Und dann kann man einfach so ein bisschen die Stimmung in dieser Diskussionsgruppe ein bisschen mitverfolgen und ich glaube, dann ist es auch nicht so schwer. Man sieht es auch im Chat hier bei Fritz, das ist eigentlich eine ganz simple Sache. Da haben sich mehrere Leute eingebürgert, die relativ regelmäßig da sind und es gibt oft Leute, die zum ersten Mal reingucken, die sind manchmal, kommen sie total schnell in diese Gruppe rein, dass man sich mit allen zusammen unterhält und manchmal haben sie es schwieriger und das liegt aber oft daran, dass wir irgendwie mit der Caps Lock Taste erstmal, boah, endlose Sätze da reinhacken. Also alles groß geschrieben und dann haben wir hier gerade so einen wunderbaren Fall gehabt, irgendwie 80.000 Mal reinschreiben, Amiga ist toll oder sich jetzt zum Beispiel unter meinem Namen einloggen und ein bisschen Quatsch schreiben. Also so eine Leute haben einfach Idiot auf der Stirn tätowiert und mit denen redet man nicht so gerne. Deswegen ist der Umgang untereinander einfach nicht ganz unwichtig.
Ja, das bringt uns vielleicht mal darauf auch mal auf etwas hinzuweisen, was es gibt seitens dem es das Internet gibt, was heutzutage allerdings wenig gehört findet, das ist die Netiquette. Ein Dokument, was man sehr einfach findet, die Netiquette, also eine Mischung aus Net und Etikette. Das ist eine kleine Datei, die einen einfachen... Bitte?
Mit QUU. Mit QUU.
Schreibt doch mal was zur Netiquette war, das liegt dir sicher nicht sehr nahe.
Ja, da gibt es zum einen die sogenannten Nickelnetze oder Tiernetze und zum anderen die Use Groups im Internet und die unterscheiden sich unter anderem in der Netiquette. In den kleinen Netzen schreibt sich die Netiquette mit K wie Kette und angekettet und das ist also teilweise etwas deutscher und hausmeisterlicher.
Du meinst die Glockwartige?
Wir sagen ja auch nicht Idiot, sondern intellektuell ausbauffähig. In den Use Groups schreibt sich die Netiquette mit QU. Es ist eben auch sehr hilfreich, erstmal die zu lesen und zu finden. Die findet sich eben auch in de New User Questions. Oder wenn man in Deja News reingeht, das ist sowieso hilfreich. Wenn man ein bestimmtes Wort hat, also beispielsweise wie benutze ich Remailer, wie bewege ich mich auf dem Netz, dann geht man in Deja News und gibt als Suchbegriff den wirklich gesuchten Begriff Remailer, als zweiten Begriff FAQ zusammengeschrieben und als dritten Begriff und. Weil und ist ein so häufiges deutsches Wort, dass man damit nur die FAQs, die in Deutsch sind, rausfindet. Und da hat man drei Begriffe getippt, kriegt vielleicht so ein Dutzend Antworten. Und da muss man sich dann erst mal durchschmelkern. Und dann hat man zumindest einen Orientierungspunkt und dann kann man weitermachen.
Und dann gibt es auch noch Fragen, auf die es wahrscheinlich nie eine Antwort geben wird. Zum Beispiel auf die Frage, warum steht auf meinem Monitor hier im Studio gerade? Netscape verursachte eine allgemeine Schutzverletzung im Modul Netscape Excel an Adresse 003BC41B. Da gibt es übrigens noch einen Tipp für Windows User. Das ist die Tastenkombination, die alles rettet, die heißt ALT.
Alte Steuerung entfernen. Das ist der Wendegriff, mit dem man eine Revolution auslöst im Periodischen. Und am Computer ist das alte Steuerung entfernen, also die Regierung absetzen.
Vielleicht auch noch ein anderer Satz zum Thema Suchmaschinen und Suchen im Internet. Eine Sache, die vielleicht für viele Leute ganz logisch klingt, die es aber nicht ist. Also das hab ich in Mails auch festgestellt, die ich bekomme. Wenn man in internationalen Suchmaschinen sucht, sollte man zumindest kurz mal ins Wörterbuch gucken und sich den englischen Begriff für das, was man sucht, raussuchen. Englisch ist, liegt einfach in der Geschichte des Internets, einfach zu 80 Prozent die Sprache des Internets. Deswegen ist es, wenn man es ein bisschen lernt, auf keinen Fall ein Fehler, auch wenn man deutsche Information sucht. Das wird immer mehr im Netz, aber wie gesagt, also 80 Prozent, würde ich schätzen, ist einfach Englisch. Deswegen auch zum Beispiel die Angabe der Newsgroup-Namen auf Englisch, selbst wenn das Thema Deutsch ist, das sieht man dann am DE, im Namen, weil es gibt zum Beispiel spanische Newsgroups oder so, wenn ich irgendwie Informationen aus Spanien brauche, ist es wirklich absolut Quatsch, wenn diese ganzen Newsgroups spanische Titel haben. Weil ich weiß nicht, worum es geht und ich könnte aber, wenn ich den Namen am Namen sehen würde, da unterhalten sich Spanier über ein Thema, wozu ich eine Frage habe, könnte ich vielleicht versuchen, ob da jemand Englisch spricht oder vielleicht sogar jemand ein bisschen Deutsch versteht oder ich könnte mit ein wenig Spanisch versuchen, mich verständlich zu machen. Wenn aber der Name der Newsgroup schon für mich redselhaft ist, dann habe ich da keine Chance, mich einzumischen oder eine Frage zu stellen. Deswegen ist es ein bisschen englisch können oder, je mehr, desto besser auf keinen Fall falsch. Mal lieber nicht. Babelfisch, wir können kurz die Adresse sagen, wer das will. Das ist babelfischaltavista.com.
atomaltavista.com, hier gibt es einen Link.
Aber ich glaube, es funktioniert auch mit babelfischaltavista.com. Das ist eine Übersetzungsmaschine im Internet.
altavista.com ist nicht die Dütche, sondern es ist eine andere Site, die die Menschen gerne kaufen würden, wenn sie sich kaufen lassen würden, aber sie verdienen mehr damit, Werbung zu schalten, weil alle Leute sich verzünden.
Dann sag nochmal die richtige Adresse von Altavista. altavista.digital.com Ansonsten ist dieser Babelfisch-altavista-programm ein Programm, das automatisch Webseiten übersetzt. Das tut es natürlich Wort für Wort. Wenn man sich zum Beispiel eine Seite von Pearl Jam übersetzen lässt, dann steht da Perlenstau und das sind einfach sehr lustige Geschichten. Wobei das ja sogar eine richtige Übersetzung ist, aber Sätze machen da meistens wenig Sinn.
Ich tippe mal das deutsche Grundgesetz einmal nach Englisch und wieder zurück nach Deutsch übersetzen. Das ist schon ein guter Spaß zum An-die-Wand-Hängen auf einer netten Party.
Also wenn man seinen Kumpels zeigen will, dass Internet echt klasse ist, dann sollte sie das angucken, um für ein paar Lacher zu saugen.
Kleiner Tipp noch zum Spanischen. Dort sind die URLs nicht mit einem Schrägstrich, der nach vorne fällt, sondern mit dem Rückstrich.
Ach, tatsächlich?
Das darfst du mich nicht fragen.
Da sind auch die Anführungszeichen andersrum.
Das ist eben auch so ein Problem wie mit Umlaut, nur am Anfang.
Und dann? Richtig. Die machen sozusagen Tags.
Bei der Frage vorne ein umgekehrtes Fragezeichen und hinten ein richtiges.
Dann haben die ja gar kein Problem mit HTML.
Das ist auch eine super Methode.
Das ist eine sehr schöne Sprache.
Das ist meine letzte Tätowierung aus Spanien. War aber eine Holländische Tätowiererin übrigens. Du, ich sag dir, ich sammel die Viennner Leute auf ihre Kopfhände.
Und dann lässt du die wieder wegläsern.
Nee, nee, nee, die.
Bleiben. Wer Lust hat, sich auch weiterhin kreativ mit Technologie auseinanderzusetzen, der hätte vielleicht auch Lust, uns mal besuchen zu kommen im CCC Berlin. Wir machen alle zwei Wochen einen Treff, der heißt Club Discordia.
Das ist sozusagen alle zwei Wochen an einem Donnerstag.
Informationen dazu findet ihr unter www.ccc.de.
Ansonsten Feedback für die Radiosendungen wünschen wir uns immer sehr. Kriegen wir allerdings nicht so viel.
Chaos.orb.de.
Deswegen können wir keine Mail.
Schickt uns bloß keine Mail.
Es gab auch Probleme mit dem Ticker, ne?
Ja, ja. Also in den letzten Wochen war eigentlich alles ganz schön im Eimer irgendwie mit dem Mail. Und ich würde sagen, wir versprechen jetzt mal, das mal zu überprüfen, wie der aktuelle Stand ist. Und dann steht das, und das funktioniert auf jeden Fall auf chaosradio.ccc.de.
Das ist die Anlaufstellung, da stehen auch alle anderen Informationen.
Ähm, ja, das war's.
Gleich kommt's Martin Petersdorf mit dem Night Flight.
Und vorher gibt's noch ein bisschen schöne Musik.
Bis dann, tschüss!